What did the ocean say to the beach? Nothing, it just waved. Nice, okay. It's pretty good. You want one last one? Yeah, please. Where do you learn to make a banana split? I don't know where.
海洋对海滩说了什么？什么也没说，它只是挥了挥手。不错，行吧。挺不错的。还要听最后一个吗？行，请吧。你在哪儿学会做香蕉船的？我不知道在哪儿。
Sunday school. Oh, man, that's good. Welcome to Smartless banana split. I don't know where. Sunday school. Oh, man, that's good. Welcome to Smartless, everybody. Welcome, everyone. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart.
主日学校。天哪，那太棒了。欢迎来到《聪明绝顶》香蕉船。我不知道在哪儿。主日学校。天哪，那太棒了。欢迎来到《聪明绝顶》，大家好。欢迎大家。聪明。聪明。聪明。聪明。
Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart.
聪明。聪明。聪明。聪明。聪明。聪明。聪明。聪明。
Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. I've been watching all these interviews with William Freakin, who direct the movies that we can't name, but amazing interviews. Are we celebrating a life lost? Yeah, we are. He was a tremendous artist and just one of the funny things I just read this thing, so I'm talking about going to this,
聪明。聪明。聪明。聪明。聪明。我一直在看所有这些对弗瑞金·威廉的采访，他导演了那些我们说不出名字的电影，但采访太精彩了。我们在庆祝一个逝去的生命吗？是的，我们在庆祝。他是一位伟大的艺术家，而且我刚读到一件趣事，所以我在谈论去这个，
speaking to these students and the students, and I'm about to shoot my student film, what format should I shoot it at? And he said, who gives a shit? Is that true? William said that. I'm sure you're stirring. Oh, maybe, maybe,
跟这些学生们交流，然后学生们说，我正准备拍我的学生电影，我该用什么格式拍？他说，谁他妈在乎啊？真的吗？威廉那么说的。我敢肯定你在煽风点火。哦，也许，也许，
I'm, he directed a scary movie that I can't watch today because it's so scary. Hey, Sean, I know we talk about this a lot, but it's enough from me, from my mouth. What? No. You being in New York. I know. I know. So dumb. Can we have a date? Now, I'm sure this is going to air past the day because I feel like we're close.
我，他导演了一部恐怖片，我现在都不敢看，因为太吓人了。嘿，肖恩，我知道我们经常谈论这个，但从我这里、从我嘴里说出来的已经够多了。什么？没有。你身在纽约。我知道。我知道。太蠢了。我们能约个会吗？现在，我确信这期节目播出时已经过那个日子了，因为我觉得我们很近。
How much longer? Three weeks, 21, Sean. Sean, I got sent a picture yesterday from somebody whom you do not know, my friend Elizabeth, and she sent me a photo of her partner, a center photo of her. She didn't want to leave her seat, and he took a photo,
还要多久？三周，21天，肖恩。肖恩，昨天有人给我发了一张照片，那个人你并不认识，我的朋友伊丽莎白，她给我发了一张她伴侣的照片，发了一张她的照片。她不想离开座位，他拍了一张照片，
because she was out your show in the balcony, and she was so moved. She was sat there for like 20 minutes, like just reacting to it. She was so moved by you for so nice. It's so nice. Yeah, wow. It was two nights ago. I mean, that's so nice. That's your story. Yeah, wow. It was too nice to go.
因为她去了你的演出，在楼座，她感动得不行。她在那里坐了大约20分钟，就只是做出反应。她被你感动得——太棒了。太棒了。是啊，哇。那是两天前的事。我的天，太棒了。那是你的故事。是啊，哇。那是两天前的事。
I mean, that's so sweet. It's, it's, please tell her, thank you. And, um, wait, two things though. One is Scotty being stuck here, J. T. Your Point, treated me to a helicopter ride the other day. Will. Yeah. Hopefully he wasn't flying. No, he was not flying. Okay. And we flew so close to, because we haven't left.
我是说，太甜了。请代我向她道谢，还有，等等，两件事。第一是斯科蒂被困在这里，J.T.，正如你所说，前几天请我坐了直升机。威尔。是啊。希望不是他在开。不，不是他开的。好吧。我们飞得那么近，因为我们已经六个月没离开了。
They're done anything in six months. Um six months, lyric apartment theater, apartment theater. And, uh, and so we flew around and the Kyla copper came really close to the Statue of Liberty. Like, really close. It was unbelievable. I never seen it that close. So Scotty just said, hey, let's go take a helicopter trip around the city. Yeah, because we haven't done anything just to do something. Just to tell you. Sounds great. Have you ever done that? No, I would love to.
他们六个月什么都没做，嗯，六个月，抒情公寓剧院，公寓剧院。然后，然后我们就到处飞，那架直升机飞得离自由女神像非常近。真的非常近。太令人难以置信了。我从来没见过它那么近。所以斯科蒂就说，嘿，我们去坐直升机绕城兜风吧。是啊，因为我们什么都没做，就为了找点事做。就为了告诉你。听起来很棒。你以前做过吗？没有，我很想去。
Now, I'm a little, I'm not a huge fan of helicopters. I love their mobility, their flexibility, and all that stuff. But, you know, there's zero glide potential. I get it's the glide. It's the glide. What do you mean glide? Well, I mean, it's sort of a, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's fools comfort anyway to think, you know, the plane has glide potential if the, if the engines go to
现在，我有点，我不是直升机的大粉丝。我喜欢它们的机动性、灵活性以及诸如此类的东西。但是，你知道，滑翔潜力为零。我懂，就是滑翔。就是滑翔。你说的滑翔是什么意思？嗯，我的意思是，这有点，这有点，这有点，这有点，这可以说是自欺欺人的安慰，认为你知道，如果引擎出故障，飞机是有滑翔潜力的，如果引擎
shit. Well, the guy told me that, the guy's like, because I'm like, what's the plan? He's like, oh, no, if the end, you started the trip, we were in the air. And I talked about it. I shouldn't have, because it freaked me out. And he goes, look, if the engines fail, and they won't, he goes, you just glide down to the bottom. It's got like that potential. So is he like helicopter does it? Yeah, what kind of helicopter were we on? Did it have a bunch of, I don't know, is it was a wings on it? Or a bunch of birds attached to it? You're seeing a second kid who's dropped. Just falls, man. Yeah, I mean, there's, there's some physics and yeah, so anyway, I mean, listen Don't think that's how any of us none of our listeners none of us. That's not how we're going no
完蛋了。嗯，那家伙告诉我，那家伙就像是——因为我问，计划是什么？他说，哦，不，如果引擎在旅程开始时，我们还在空中。我谈到了它。我不该说的，因为它把我吓坏了。他说，听着，如果引擎失效——而且它们不会——他说，你只要滑翔到底部就行了。它有那种滑翔潜力。所以他是说直升机可以这样？对，我们坐的是什么直升机？上面有一堆，我不知道，上面有翅膀吗？还是绑了一堆鸟？你看到的第二个孩子直接掉下去了。直接就坠落了，老兄。是啊，我的意思是，这里面有一些物理原理，对吧，所以无论如何，我的意思是，听着，不要认为任何一个——我们的听众中没有一个人，我们中没有一个人。这不是我们要去的——不
I know I know what you mean when the thing took off and you know wobbles when it takes off left to right left to right Yeah, and it's like it's pretty scary. You're gonna choke on a wanton one day And that's how you're gonna go Like I can get one morning here And that'll how you're gonna go. Like, Scotty, I can get one more in here. Give it a minute, man. And that'll be it for you. Just a word to one time. Oh, one time. Sorry, you kidding?
我知道，我知道你是什么意思，当那东西起飞时，你知道起飞时会摇晃，从左到右，从左到右，对，这挺可怕的。你总有一天会因为吃馄饨而噎死，这就是你的下场。就像我可以在这里再吃一个，这就是你的下场。就像，斯科蒂，我可以在这里再吃一个。等一下，老兄。那你就彻底完蛋了。就因为一个馄饨。哦，一个馄饨。抱歉，你在开玩笑吗？
That sounds pretty. He's gonna choke on the fucking heel of a loaf of wonder. He's like, well, I'm still bread. I'll just have the heel. There's a little bit of that. Hold it on, son. You ever make bread balls, or you take the center of the white bread
听起来挺好。他会因为吃整条神奇白面包的硬皮而他妈的噎死。他会说，嗯，我还是喜欢面包。我就吃硬皮吧。有点那种意思。坚持住，儿子。你揉过面团球吗，就是你把白面包的中心部分
and you just, we'll ball it up with a something. Look at it, it's a bread meat ball. I collect heels. I just make heels. All my sandwiches are from heels of loads of bread. We ate, we ate tortillas, just a tortilla. You know shit, what's 9am? So that makes sense.
然后你把它揉成一个球，用点什么东西。你看，这是一个面包肉丸。我收集面包硬皮。我只做硬皮。我的三明治全是用整条面包的硬皮做的。我们吃，我们吃玉米饼，就只是玉米饼。你知道个屁，几点了？所以这说得通。
Hey, listen. We never make bread balls. You. Whatever, my bright ball. Hey, you know, you know, I love me some music. I love music. And, and I love all kinds of different music. Man, I always have. I've always had a, I like to think that I have an eclectic taste because sometimes I think, well, I'm just kind of a dinosaur,
嘿，听着。我们从来不揉面团球。你。随便吧，我的面团球。嘿，你知道，你知道，我喜欢音乐。我喜欢音乐。而且，我喜欢各种各样的音乐。老兄，我一直都这样。我一直都有，我总觉得自己品味挺 eclectic（折衷）的，因为有时我想，好吧，我只是那种恐龙，
sort of 90s indie rock guy, but I'm not. I'm kind of all over the place. You're the one tall Paul Simon to go down to Africa and do Graceland, right? You're on the inspiration for him. You've explored these sounds? But I've been into, you know, we've had a lot of great musicians on the show,
有点90年代独立摇滚风格的家伙，其实并不是。我涉猎很广。你就是那个让保罗·西蒙去非洲制作《格雷斯兰》的高人，对吧？你是他的灵感来源？你探索过这些声音吗？但我一直很喜欢，你知道，我们节目上有很多伟大的音乐家，
and I've been a friend of them all, whether it's from sort of new wave or, you know, whatever, to classic rock and roll, to, you know, whatever, to classic rock and roll, to, you know, I don't know, just everything. Think about it. And today's guest is such a representative of an entire genre of music that they kind of inspired so many musicians, and not just of their genre, but of all genres. It's so rare when somebody
我跟他们所有人都成了朋友，无论是新浪潮，还是别的什么，到经典摇滚，再到，你知道，别的什么，到经典摇滚，再到，你知道，我不知道，就是各种各样。想想看。今天的嘉宾简直代表了一种全方位的音乐流派，他们激励了如此多的音乐家，不仅在他们的流派内，而且在所有流派中。当某个人
from one genre is able to inspire people across all different types of music. You got Madonna. This person, this person is, he's, he's, he's, he joined us from overseas, born in Denmark, and then moved to the U.S. and formed a band that has sold nearly 120 million albums worldwide. That's my... Generating more than 15 billion streams. He's from Denmark? Yeah, I mean, nine Grammy Awards, two American Music Awards, multiple MTV Movie Video Awards, 2009 induction into the Rock and Roll Hall of Fame.
来自某个流派，却能够激励所有不同类型音乐的人时，这太罕见了。你有麦当娜。这个人，这个人，他，他，他，他是从海外加入我们的，在丹麦出生，然后移居美国，组建了一支在全球售出近1.20万张专辑的乐队。这就是我的……产生了超过150亿次的流媒体播放量。他来自丹麦？是的，我是说，九座格莱美奖，两座全美音乐奖，多座MTV音乐录影带大奖，2009年入选摇滚名人堂。
Just all over the place, they've done it. All they played with everybody. This is none other than one of my all-time faves. It's Lars Ulrich of Metallica. Good Lord. Ways. And now the high-tech reveal, see if I can do this. Oh my God.
无所不包，他们都做到了。他们和所有人都合作过。这位不是别人，正是我的历来最爱之一。他就是金属乐队的拉尔斯·乌尔里希。天呐。厉害。现在是高科技揭晓环节，看我能不能做到。哦，天呐。
Oh my God. No way. No way. Also known as a high. My name is Brett Balls. I like Brett Balls. No way there. Also known as, hi, my name is breadballs. I like breadballs. That's breadballs. Breadballs, I like breadballs.
哦，天呐。不可能。不可能。也被称为高。我叫面包球。我喜欢面包球。不可能有那样的。也被称为，嗨，我叫面包球。我喜欢面包球。那是面包球。面包球，我喜欢面包球。
Oh my God. Or otherwise known as Michael Cooper's best friend. How's Cooper? Yes, that's right. Michael Cooper, he's the texting me as we're speaking and he's texting you. You know, now Michael Cooper's got one of these ailments that I think affects a lot of people
哦，天呐。或者也可以叫迈克尔·库珀的最好朋友。库珀怎么样？是的，没错。迈克尔·库珀，我们说话的时候他就在给我发短信，他也给你发短信。你知道，现在迈克尔·库珀有一种毛病，我觉得这影响了很多人
on the next thing. Tell us who Michael Cooper is. He's a friend of yours. He's a guy I used to work with. Sure. And now he's working with fans here, folks, than me. But he uses the send button as a period when he texts people. That's a, yes.
接下来。告诉我们迈克尔·库珀是谁。他是你的朋友。他是我以前共事过的一个家伙。没错。现在他跟这里的粉丝们一起工作，伙计，比我多。但他给别人发短信时，把发送键当成句号用。没错，就是这样。
That's a 23 text showing up at one time. This is a normal five minutes of Michael Cooper, but they're all sent with love and kisses. I love them. And there are pictures of himself driving. How many pictures of Michael Cooper? Do you have of him driving? Driving, showing off a watch or a new hairstyle
那是23条短信同时弹出来。这是迈克尔·库珀日常的五分钟，但它们都带着爱和亲吻发送的。我爱他们。而且全是他开车的照片。你有多少迈克尔·库珀开车的照片？开车，炫耀手表、新发型
or a new set of glasses. You know, I'm not on, I didn't sign up for the Cooper fan letter. I love him now. As long as you have an iPhone and a text message thread with him, you're in that fan club. I love him. Look at what I just want to say, one thing that,
或是一副新眼镜。你知道，我没加入，我可没报名参加库珀粉丝俱乐部。我现在爱他。只要你有一部iPhone，并且跟他有短信聊天串，你就进了那个粉丝俱乐部。我爱他。看，我只想说一件事，
and I'm sure you guys have heard this before, but you don't need guests on your show, just the seven minute banter there before the reveal. That's, that's plenty. It's all done. I've taken, I've taken some potential Metallica titles away from this. I think bread balls is the one to be. I like zero glide potential. That sounds more like an album title. Great hard rock title. Yeah, I think sure that's, you know, that's like, well, they did it before. It's called Led Zeppelin. Yeah, right.
我确信你们以前也听过这话，但你们节目根本不需要嘉宾，揭晓前那七分钟的闲聊就足够了。那，那完全够了。这就行了。我从这里顺走了一些潜在的金属乐队专辑名。我觉得“面包球”是当之无愧的。我喜欢“零滑翔潜力”。听起来更像个专辑名。很棒的硬摇滚专辑名。对，我敢肯定那，你知道，这就好比，嗯，他们以前做过。叫齐柏林飞艇。对，没错。
Zero glide. Yeah, there's a lot of bad jokes in there that we should shy away from. And then the last thing I would say also, is it Madonna? I like that one too. That's she's the mayor of all genres. Dude, dude, Lars, thank you for doing this, man. It's so great to have you. Right back at you. And I had the good fortune of hanging out just a couple times with Larris a few years
零滑翔。对，里面有很多烂笑话，我们应该避之不及。然后我要说的最后一件事也是，是麦当娜吗？我也喜欢那个。她是所有流派的市长。老兄，老兄，拉尔斯，谢谢你来参加，老兄。有你来太棒了。彼此彼此。我有幸在几年前通过共同的朋友跟拉里斯一起玩过几次
ago through mutual friends. That's right. And I've always, and of course, I didn't want to, you know, drill you with it at the time and, and Baris, you have always been such a fan of Metallica and your music. And, and one of the things that I did not know, and I guess a lot of hardcore Metallica fans did know this was I didn't know that you actually moved to the States just to play tennis. I knew that you were a tennis player and that you were a competitive tennis player, but I didn't know that that was the whole purpose of your move was to play tennis.
。没错。而且我一直，当然，我当时不想，你知道，一直缠着你，而且，拉里斯，你一直是金属乐队和他们音乐的超级粉丝。而且，我不知道的一件事，我想很多金属乐队的死忠粉也不知道这一点，我不知道你其实是为了打网球才搬到美国去的。我知道你是个网球运动员，你是个竞技网球运动员，但我不知道你搬家的全部目的就是为了打网球。
Is that true? The whole purpose was to, so my father, I grew up in Copenhagen, Denmark, as you guys circled. And you were born there? Born, yeah. Born and raised in Copenhagen. And my dad was a professional tennis player. And I come from a family of tennis players. So his brother was one of the other greats in the country.
这是真的吗？全部目的就是为了，所以我的父亲，我是在丹麦哥本哈根长大的，正如你们所知。你是在那里出生的？出生，对。在哥本哈根出生长大。我父亲是一名职业网球运动员。我来自一个网球世家。所以他的叔叔是国内另一位网球巨星。
And at one point, the Davis Cup, the Danish Davis Cup team was my dad, his brother, and the captain was their dad. So it's a long line of famous tennis grates in Denmark, and I, of course, wanted to follow in their footsteps. So when I finished school in 1979 in Denmark, I ended up in Braydenton, Florida. The first year of Nick Boleter's tennis academy. No way. And you moved because of tennis?
有一段时间，戴维斯杯，丹麦戴维斯杯队里有我爸、他叔叔，队长是他们的爸爸。所以在丹麦有一长串著名的网球巨星，我当然想追随他们的脚步。所以当我在1979年完成丹麦的学业后，我最终去了佛罗里达州布雷登顿。尼克·波利泰里网球学院的第一年。不会吧。你是为了网球才搬过去的？
Is that what you mean? Yes. Absolutely. Nick Bolotair, tennis camp, which at the time, by the way, was revolutionary. It was like the real place where a lot of these famous young tennis dedicated tennis players went. It was like the first of its kind, in my rather. Yeah.
你是这个意思吗？是的。绝对是。尼克·波利泰里网球训练营，顺便说一句，在当时是具有革命性的。它就像是真正的地方，许多这些著名的年轻网球手、奉献于网球的人都去了那里。在我看来，它可以说是同类中的第一个。是的。
And it was also a transitional time in tennis where, you know, up till the mid 70s to the late 70s, the best tennis players all over the world were the ones that had the most talent. But as it shifted in the late 70s, the best tennis players ended up becoming the ones that worked the hardest at it and played six, eight hours a day and doing drills and worked in the weight room
这也是网球的一个过渡时期，你知道，直到70年代中期到70年代末，世界各地最好的网球运动员都是那些最有天赋的人。但随着70年代末的转变，最好的网球运动员最终变成了那些最努力训练的人，他们一天打六到八个小时，做训练，在力量房里锻炼
and all this type of stuff. That there was a seismic shift in the whole setup. And I went the first year to Nick Boleteris. And then after that, we moved out to Southern California, ended up in Newport Beach, where I was going to attend Carl Del Mar High School, with my dad's friend, the tennis great from Australia, Roy Emerson, his son Anthony. And so in Denmark, up through those years, in my junior years, I was ranked in the top 10 consistently in the country.
以及所有这类事情。整个体系发生了翻天覆地的变化。我去尼克·波利泰里训练营的第一年。然后在那之后，我们搬到了南加州，最后到了纽波特海滩，我将在那里上卡尔德尔马高中，和我父亲的朋友、来自澳大利亚的网球巨星罗伊·埃森哲的儿子安东尼一起。所以，在丹麦的那些年里，在我的青少年时期，我在国内一直排在前十名。
And when I came out to Southern California and went to Colonel Dillmar High School as a junior in 11th grade, I did not, I did not. This is true, Stuart. I did not make the fucking tennis team. I was not, I did not, this is true story, I did not make the fucking tennis team. I was not, I was not one of the, I was not one of the seven best players at Crowell the Mar High School. Geez. So the whole tennis dream and following in, in the Ulrich footsteps that came crashing down, no pun intended to the zero glide potential there, but that came crashing down in one afternoon,
当我来到南加州，在1980年以11年级学生的身份去卡尔德尔马高中时，我没有，我没有。这是真的，斯图尔特。我他妈的没进网球校队。我没有，我没有，这是真事，我他妈的没进网球校队。我不是，我不是，我不是卡尔德尔马高中最好的七名球员之一。天哪。所以整个网球梦想以及追随乌尔里希家族的脚步就这样破灭了，虽然没有双关零滑翔潜力的意思，但在一个下午就彻底破灭了，
and then rock and roll was hovering, hovering in the trenches and took over. But wait, so Lars, you make this, and you sort of, you talk about it very openly in the fact that, yeah, I knew that you had this, this, come from this dynasty, this Danish, tennis, dynastic family. And then you move to, you go to Nick Bolleterri and then you come to Southern California. And like you see in one afternoon, like all of a sudden, what they put, you try out, they put out the list for the tennis team, you're not on it. And you're like, well, there goes everything. Like, that was that. Yeah. I mean, you know, I've heard myself obviously tell that story 9,000 times. So it, it, it gets shorter and shorter and becomes more of a sound bite.
然后摇滚乐在战壕里徘徊，最终接管了一切。但是等等，所以拉尔斯，你经历了这个，而且你，你谈到这一点时非常坦诚，是的，我知道你有这个，出身于这个王朝，这个丹麦网球王朝家庭。然后你搬到，你去了尼克·波利泰里，然后你来到南加州。就像你在一个下午看到的那样，突然之间，他们贴出网球校队的名单，上面没有你的名字。然后你就想，好吧，一切都完了。就这样了。是的。我的意思是，你知道，我自己显然听过自己讲这个故事9000遍了。所以，它变得越来越短，更像是一个声音片段。
But it is pretty much what happened. Music was always hovering. And music was my escape away from the discipline of tennis. And I'd been playing both guitar and drums in Denmark. And as you, I was 17 at the time, as you, you get a little older, and you start drinking a few beers, and looking at the girls differently, and blah, blah, blah, blah, and things change.
但基本上就是这么回事。音乐一直在周围徘徊。音乐是我逃避网球纪律的避难所。我在丹麦既弹过吉他，也打过鼓。如你所知，我当时17岁，随着你年龄增长，开始喝几杯啤酒，对女孩有不同的看法，等等等等，事情就变了。
And, but I was, it pretty much came crashing down. That's why. Did you teach yourself to play guitar and drums, or were you doing it like through a, in school? In Denmark. In school. What language are they speaking, Denmark? They speak Danish.
但是，我，它基本上就那样崩溃了。这就是为什么。你是自学弹吉他和打鼓的，还是通过学校的课程？在丹麦。在学校。他们在丹麦说什语言？他们说丹麦语。
And he's... He's trying to contact you for a second. Sorry, Lars. So sorry for one second. So sorry, dude. And you still speak it? Just a second. I'm not a third, Danzke.
他在……他想联系你一下。对不起，拉尔斯。非常抱歉一秒钟。非常抱歉，老兄。你还会说吗？等一下。我不是一个第三级的丹麦人。
I have stayed to take Danzke. I have 100% Danzke, or I... But your mic's going out. Ville, Danzke. You're going over. I'm still, I'm still proudly, you know, there's only five million of us and we keep it, we keep it loud and proud and I'm still a Danish citizen actually and still travel on my Danish passport.
我一直是百分之百的丹麦人，或者我……但你的麦克风快没声音了。威尔，丹麦语。你要超过了。我仍然，我仍然自豪地，你知道，我们只有五00万人，我们保持着高调和自豪，实际上我仍然是一名丹麦公民，依然拿着我的丹麦护照旅行。
Wow, that's so cool. Yeah. Now, so, so then, so that you learn these two instruments in, in school, it in school, it wasn't a music school, was it? Or was just a... No, no, it was just Danish public school. Pick an elective and band was one of them and you gravitated towards those two instruments. Was that that simple?
哇，太酷了。是的。现在，所以，所以然后，你是在学校里学会这两种乐器的，是在学校里吗？那不是一所音乐学校吧？还是只是一个……不，不，只是丹麦的公立学校。选修一门课，乐队是其中之一，你就自然而然地被这两种乐器吸引了。就这么简单吗？
Ish, yeah, yeah. I mean, I was, my dad, my dad's passion away from tennis was also music, so I grew up in a very musically rich household. You know, there was a lot of, you know, all the jazz greats from Miles Davis to Cold Train, to Charlie Parker, to Dexter Gordon, all these, you know, and a lot of Hendrix and Doors and Rolling Stones playing out of my dad's music room all the time.
差不多吧，对，对。我的意思是，我，我父亲在网球之外的激情也是音乐，所以我是在一个音乐氛围非常浓厚的家庭里长大的。你知道，有很多，你知道，所有的爵士乐巨星，从迈尔斯·戴维斯到科尔特恩，到查理·帕克，到德克斯特·戈登，所有这些，你知道，还有很多亨德里克斯、大门乐队和滚石乐队的音乐一直在父亲的音乐室里播放。
So there was a lot of music in the family and in the household. Was there a particular band or drummer or guitarist that got you to want to, you know, jump into those two instruments? Or was it just that? When I was, I started going to concerts in Denmark early. I was nine years old when I went to see Deep Purple. And over the next couple of years, like 74, 75, I saw bands like The Sweet and Slade and Status Quo and Kiz came to Denmark in 76 and then it started to grab it,
所以家里和家庭里有很多音乐。有没有哪个特定的乐队、鼓手或吉他手让你想要，你知道，涉足这两种乐器？还是仅仅因为这个？当我，我开始很小的时候就在丹麦看演唱会。我九岁的时候去看过深紫乐队。在接下来的几年里，比如74、75年，我看了像The Sweet、Slade、Status Quo这样的乐队，Kiss在76年去了丹麦，然后就开始吸引我，
you know, going into Thin Lizzy and Rainbow and so on. But Deep Purple was my first real music experience and has always been the North Star for me. What about drummers? Who are the drummers that you were like? Yes. Ian Pace from Deep Purple, the guy with the round glasses, who was just insane driving Deep Purple. I gravitated towards also Phil Rudd from ACDC, who's obviously very different than Ian Pace. But he was a huge inspiration.
你知道，开始听瘦 lizzy、彩虹乐队等等。但深紫乐队是我真正的第一次音乐体验，并且一直是我的北极星。鼓手呢？让你惊叹的鼓手有哪些？深紫乐队的伊恩·佩斯，戴着圆眼镜的那个家伙，他疯狂地推动着深紫乐队的节奏。我还被AC/DC的菲尔·鲁德吸引，他显然和伊恩·佩斯很不一样。但他是一个巨大的灵感来源。
How did it go over with your family? That was, you say I was a big tennis family, I'm assuming that there wasn't a lot of hard rock happening in the car on the way back and forth to the court. It's like, how did they feel about that? Although it was a lot of... There was a lot of anything happening in the car because I bite to school,
你家人对这事的反应如何？那是，你说这是一个庞大的网球世家，我猜在来回球场的车里肯定没放多少硬滚音乐。就像，他们对此怎么看？尽管有很多……车里有很多各种声音，因为我从二年级开始就骑自行车去学校，
starting in second grade. That big sort of career pivot for you and lifestyle pivot for you, were they cool with that? Yeah, my dad was very forgiving with all that. Like I said before, his passion was music. He actually wrote about jazz music
对于你那种巨大的人生转型和生活方式转型，他们能接受吗？是的，我父亲对所有这些都很宽容。就像我之前说的，他的激情是音乐。他实际上还为一些丹麦出版物
for some Danish publications. And at that time, excuse me, in the 50s and 60s, especially Copenhagen, but Stockholm to a degree in obviously Paris were just the European, havens for American jazz music. So many of the American jazz grades came to Europe, spent a lot of time on Scandinavia. People like Ben Webster lived in Copenhagen,
撰写过关于爵士乐的文章。在那个时候，打扰一下，在50年代和60年代，特别是哥本哈根，斯德哥尔摩在某种程度上，以及巴黎，简直就是美国爵士乐在欧洲的天堂。许多美国爵士巨星来到欧洲，在斯堪的纳维亚半岛度过了很多时间。像本·韦伯斯特住在哥本哈根，
Dexter Gordon lived in Copenhagen, John Chi-Kai, but Copenhagen was very much a hotbed for jazz music at the time. Growing up to, like, kind of at Jason's point, where you, your parent, because I was like, I we live we grew up in a super small house And I was always playing piano practice piano and drove everybody crazy because it was so tiny How in the world like Jason will what if your kids just I don't dad want to play drums? I mean that going on in the house constantly
德克斯特·戈登住在哥本哈根，约翰·奇凯，但当时的哥本哈根很大程度上是爵士乐的热土。就像杰森说的那样，你的父母，因为我觉得，我们是在一所超级小的房子里长大的，我一直在弹钢琴，练习钢琴，把所有人都快逼疯了，因为房子太小了。到底怎么回事——杰森，万一你的孩子，如果我爸爸想打我的鼓？我的意思是，那在家里不是天天都在发生吗？
We got the electric we got the electric ones now with it with the head Yeah, yeah, that's you're right. That's true. No, we didn't have that back in the day, right, Lars? They didn't have those back in the day. No, we, I had a room down in the basement, where I had a little music room where I had my records and my record player. And I got a drum kit, a small piece together drum kit down. And I could bash away down in the basement and do my thing down there without pissing off too many of us.
我们现在有电动的了，带耳机的那种，对，对，你说的对，那是真的。不，我们那时候可没有，对吧，拉尔斯？他们那时候可没有那种东西。没有，我们，我在地下室有一个房间，那里有一个小音乐室，我把唱片和唱片机放在那里。我弄了一套鼓，一套拼凑起来的小鼓放在那儿。我可以在地下室里尽情砸着玩，在那里做我自己的事，而不会惹恼太多人。
So good. I can imagine that going through the house all the time. I mean, it's great that you did it. And everybody did it. Now Lars, us soft actors, we fantasize about life on the, you're pretty soft too. Well, you're hard rock, you know, traveling and touring and having all that fun. And what you look so good, so healthy, so not like you've been on the road in like arguably
太棒了。我可以想象那声音在房子里回荡。我的意思是，你能做到这一点真的很棒。每个人都这么做。现在拉尔斯，我们这些娇弱的演员，幻想着……你也挺娇弱的。好吧，你是硬摇滚，你知道，旅行、巡演，享受所有那些乐趣。你看起来气色真好，那么健康，一点也不像那些在路上跑了，可以说是
the biggest rock and roll band ever for years and years and years, has the touring change now in the past decade or so such that you don't look like death warmed over. What's, how is it all working now? You guys get to bed early. It's now a shake. Another good title. It's not 30 beers. It's just 15.
史上最大的摇滚乐队，年复一年巡演的人。这过去十年左右的巡演有变化吗，以至于你看上去不像死过一次一样？现在这一切是怎么运作的？你们很早就上床睡觉了。现在是奶昔。又一个好名字。不再是30杯啤酒了。只有15杯。
Yeah, it's a protein shake, right? It's a mindfulness. Yeah, you know, in the short answer is yes. You know, we just played a couple shows out at MetLife Stadium on Friday and Sunday here in New York where I'm checking in from and worn away up to Montreal in a couple days. Right. Right now we're playing every Friday and Sunday for the rest of the summer. We play two shows in each city.
对，是蛋白粉奶昔，对吧？是正念。是的，你知道，简短的回答是“是的”。你知道，我们在纽约——我正从这里连线——的在大都会人寿体育场刚演了几场周五和周日的演出，过几天就要去蒙特利尔了。没错。现在整个夏天，我们每周五和周日都有演出。我们在每个城市演两场。
So the travel is less and it's a weekend thing. And it is, it's protein shakes, it's tofu, it's vegetables. If my 20 or 30 year old self was on this podcast with your guys, he would be sitting going, what the fuck are you talking about? But you know, 42 years in, obviously you have to, to make these changes and growing up in a, you know, around tennis and growing up around sports. It's not that difficult for me to be rigid and disciplined. I barely drink.
所以旅行变少了，成了一个周末的活动。而且，这确实是蛋白粉奶昔，是豆腐，是蔬菜。如果20岁或30岁的我跟你们几个在这个播客上，他会坐在那儿说，你们他妈的在胡说八道些什么？但你知道，42年下来，显然你必须做出这些改变，而且在网球和体育运动中长大。对我来说，保持严格和自律并不难。我几乎不喝酒。
I haven't had a drink in three months. I'll have a half a class of champagne and that's it occasionally, but other than that. Still playing tennis? I still do play tennis. Yeah, I love playing tennis and I love sports and I love being engaged and I work out. They have me chained to a peloton. Most of the time when I'm not doing podcast or playing watch shows. And so I do work out a lot. But it is true about the protein shakes
我已经三个月没喝酒了。我偶尔会喝半杯香槟，就那样，除此之外没有了。还在打网球吗？我还在打网球。是的，我喜欢打网球，我喜欢体育运动，我喜欢保持专注，我一直在锻炼。当我不在做播客或看演出的时候，他们把我锁在动感单车上。所以我确实经常锻炼。但关于蛋白粉奶昔是真的，
and we have a fortune to have a, you know, our great chef Simon who travels with us and hands us all kinds of healthy and it's healthy drinks and it's good. Listen, we've lived it. Lots of crazy fun. I mean, also we started, James and I met when I was 17. He was 18. We started Metallica. We put our first record out when we were, when I was 19 and we were touring the world, 19 and 20.
我们很幸运能有一位伟大的厨师西蒙，他跟我们一起旅行，给我们提供各种健康的食物，还有健康的饮料，这很好。听着，我们经历过这一切。有很多疯狂的乐趣。我的意思是，我们刚开始的时候，詹姆斯和我见面时我17岁。他18岁。我们组建了金属乐队。我们发行第一张唱片时，我19岁，我们在世界各地巡演，19岁和20岁。
So we started early. Just some amazing. And, you know, you got to, you got to, we got a lot of that fun stuff out of the way. And I can access a good part of those memories when I want to some of them live really far back there behind doors that that are hard to open and probably shouldn't be opened. Yeah. this year and the only way to play shows like we just did out at MetLife Stadium here is to be in the best shape you can be. So, you know, all kidding aside and clichés. Yes, it is obviously pretty different than it was 20, 30 years ago and thankfully so because the victory now is the perseverance and being able to still do it. And that's kind of what
所以我们很早就开始了。真是太棒了。而且，你知道，你得，你得，我们把那些疯狂的事情都抛在脑后了。当我想的时候，我可以接触到那些美好的回忆，其中有些记忆藏得很深，在那些很难打开、也许根本不应该打开的门后面。是的。今年，要在像我们刚在大都会人寿体育场那样的地方演出，唯一的办法就是保持最佳状态。所以，抛开玩笑和陈词滥调不谈。是的，这显然与20、30年前很不相同，谢天谢地，因为现在的胜利是坚持不懈，并且能够继续做下去。这就是
motivates us. Yeah, I bet it doesn't. I bet you can't imagine. I bet you're speaking about your younger selves. I bet you're 17 year old self when you met James Headfield and you guys formed Metallica. Can you imagine that all these years later, you guys would still be fucking rocking out and going and playing stadiums around the world. Yeah, it's pretty crazy. We've just, we've been playing. So I looked into it the other day. So we've played out it used to be called giant stadium
激励我们的动力。是的，我敢打赌是的。我敢打赌你无法想象。我敢打赌你在谈论年轻时的自己。我敢打赌，当你遇到詹姆斯·海菲尔德你们组建金属乐队时，你那个17岁的自己。你能想象多年后，你们俩依然在摇滚，在世界各地的体育场演出吗？是的，这挺疯狂的。我们一直在演出。所以我前几天查了一下。我们在以前被称为巨人体育场的地方演过
Now you have to say met life so you don't because you get into a whole divisive conversation That naming a giant in the jets. You don't want to you don't want to do that around here But we've played I just looked it up. We've played giant stadium nine times and And we've had an obviously a relationship with a greater New York tri-state area, whatever you wanna call it, for four plus decades. The two shows we just played this weekend were the two biggest shows we've ever played
现在你必须说大都会人寿，这样你就不会陷入关于巨人队和喷气机队命名的那种分裂性的对话中。你不会想在这个地方谈论这个的。但我们演过，我刚刚查了一下。我们在巨人体育场演过九次，
in New York City. So that, that's amazing. So that's not a, hey, look how great big Metallica is or whatever. That's about the music scene, that's about post-COVID people want to come out and live again. That's about hard rock still. But they're not coming out for everybody, you know. You deserve credit for the longevity and the relevance and the quality of the music
显然我们与大纽约三州地区，无论你怎么称呼它，有着四代人的联系。我们这个周末刚刚演的两场演出是我们有史以来在纽约市演过最大的两场演出。所以，这很惊人。所以这并不是在炫耀金属乐队有多么伟大之类的事情。这关乎音乐现场，这关乎疫情后人们想要出来重新生活。这依然关乎硬摇滚。但他们不是为所有人出来的，你知道的。你配得上长盛不衰、持续的相关性、音乐的质量，
and your relationship with your fans and all of us up, your mental health, right? Because if you guys were a disaster, people would probably get turned off by if there was a bunch of infighting and all that garbage. So you've kept it all together. Thank you. I appreciate that.
以及你与粉丝的关系，还有我们所有人，你的心理健康，对吧？因为如果你们是一群烂摊子，如果有很多内讧和那些垃圾事，人们可能会对此感到反感。所以你们把一切都凝聚在了一起。谢谢。我很感激。
But I, you know, I think a significant part of what drives us to this day is that we're kind of led by the mantra of our best days are still ahead of us and our favorite record is the one we haven't made yet and that we actually made sure and professional at some point of view is for real one day. And we will be right back. Smart list is sponsored by BetterHelp. So, listen, unless you're a robot or just visiting from another planet,
但我，你知道，我认为驱动我们直到今天的关键部分是，我们一直遵循着这样的座右铭：我们最好的日子还在后头，我们最喜欢的唱片是我们还没做的那张，我们在某个职业生涯的节点确实认真对待了这一点。我们马上回来。《聪明绝顶》由BetterHelp赞助。所以，听着，除非你是个机器人或者只是从外星球来参观，
you've got thoughts. You've got thoughts that sometimes are not that friendly and are difficult to process. Now, BetterHelp is right there in the title, right? Right there in the name. You can get some help to better process these thoughts at better help. It works. Do you ever find yourself just as you're trying to fall asleep or brain suddenly won't stop
否则你脑子里会有各种想法。你脑子里有些想法有时并不那么友好，很难处理。现在，BetterHelp的名字里就包含了这个意思，对吧？就在名字里。你可以在BetterHelp获得一些帮助，以更好地处理这些想法。它确实有用。你有没有发现自己正试图入睡时，你的大脑突然停不下来了
talking. You know, do your thoughts start racing right before bed or at other inopportune moments? It turns out one great way to make those racing thoughts go ways to talk them through. With better help, therapy gives you a place to do that, so you can get out of your negative thoughts cycles and find some mental and emotional peace. If you're thinking of starting therapy, why don't you give better help a try? It's entirely online designed to be convenient, flexible, and suited to your schedule. Just fill out a brief questionnaire to get matched with a licensed therapist and switch therapists at any time for no additional charge.
喋喋不休。你知道，你的思绪是不是在临睡前或其他不合时宜的时刻开始狂飙？事实证明，让那些狂飙的思绪平静下来的一个好方法就是把它们说出来。有了BetterHelp，心理治疗为你提供了一个这样做的地方，这样你就可以摆脱消极的思维循环，找到一些心理和情感上的平静。如果你正在考虑开始心理治疗，为什么不试试BetterHelp呢？它完全在网上进行，旨在方便、灵活，适合你的日程安排。只需填写一份简短的问卷，就能与持证心理治疗师匹配，并且可以随时更换治疗师，不收取任何额外费用。
So I highly recommend just finding someone that you can just download your stuff, which at worst just treat them as a file cabinet. We can at least just deposit this stuff so they don't keep you up at night. Get a break from your thoughts with BetterHelp. Visit BetterHelp.com slash SmartLess today to get 10% off your first month.
所以我强烈建议找个人，你可以把你的烦恼都倾倒出来，最坏的情况下，就把他们当作文件柜。我们至少可以把这些东西存放在那里，这样它们就不会让你夜不能寐。通过BetterHelp让你的思绪喘口气。今天就访问BetterHelp.com斜杠SmartLess，首月即可享受九折优惠。
That's BetterHelp, H-E-L-P dot com slash SmartLess. We get support from Audible, the home of storytelling. You'll discover thousands of podcasts from popular favorites to exclusive new series, guided wellness programs, theatrical performances, comedy, and exclusive audible originals from top celebrities. We're now into experts and exciting new voices in audio. The Audible app makes it easy to listen anytime, anywhere while traveling, working out, walking, doing chores. You decide.
这就是BetterHelp，点com斜杠SmartLess。我们得到了Audible的支持，故事讲述的发源地。你会发现数以千计的播客，从热门最爱到独家新系列、引导式健康项目、戏剧表演、喜剧，以及来自顶级名人的独家Audible原创作品。我们现在邀请了音频领域的专家和令人兴奋的新声音。Audible应用程序让你随时随地都能轻松聆听，无论是在旅行、锻炼、散步还是做家务。你说了算。
One that I'm really enjoying, written by James Clear called Atomic Habits. It's just basically, you know, it's not just another self-help book, it's something that like, you can actually put these things into motion, like these ways in which to make good habits pleasantly habitual. Does that make sense?
我非常喜欢的一本，是詹姆斯·克利尔写的《原子习惯》。它基本上，你知道的，它不仅仅是又一本自助书，它是那种，你可以真正把这些东西付诸实践的东西，比如让好习惯变得令人愉快地习惯化的方法。这说得通吗？
And as James says himself, tiny changes remarkable results. New members can try Audible free for 30 days. Visit audible.com slash smartless or tech smartless to 500-500. That's audible.com slash smartless or text smartless to 500-500 to try audible free for 30 days. This show is supported in part by Zip Recruiter. We're not great at a bunch of stuff over here at SmartLess, but we are the best at a few things. Number one, Sean Hay are the best at a few things. Number one, Sean Hayes, best pianist at parties.
正如詹姆斯自己所说，微小的改变带来显著的结果。新会员可以免费试用Audible 30天。访问audible.com斜杠smartless，或发送短信smartless到500-500。这就是audible.com斜杠smartless，或者发送短信smartless到500-500，免费试用Audible 30天。本期节目得到了ZipRecruiter的部分支持。我们在《聪明绝顶》这里有很多事情做得很一般，但我们在某些事情上是最好的。第一，肖恩·海斯在某些事情上是最好的。第一，肖恩·海斯是派对上最好的钢琴家。
Okay, this guy can really tickle the ivories. Will Arnette is the best at, gosh, really nothing except maybe being the best Canadian on the podcast. The bad news there is that he's the only Canadian. Okay, so he gets something, that's a trophy. I'm the best at being long-winded and not interesting. Our sponsor, Zip Recruiter, is also the best at something. Finding top talent for your hard to fill roles.
好吧，这家伙真的能弹得一手好琴。威尔·阿奈特最擅长的是，天哪，真的没什么，除了可能是播客里最好的加拿大人。坏消息是，他是唯一的加拿大人。好吧，他得到了点东西，这是一个奖杯。我最擅长的是喋喋不休且毫无趣。我们的赞助商ZipRecruiter也在某方面是最好的。为你的难招岗位寻找顶尖人才。
So if you need to hire, you can try Zip Recruiter right now for free at ziprecruoter.com slash smartless. Zippercrooter's powerful technology does the work for you. It scans thousands of resumes to find great matches for your job. Zippercrooter lets you invite the most qualified people to apply for your job to help you stand out amongst the competition. When it comes to hiring, go with the best. Zippercrooter 4 out of 5 employers who post on Zippercruder, yet a quality candidate
所以如果你需要招聘，你现在就可以在ziprecruiter.com斜杠smartless上免费试用ZipRecruiter。Ziprecruiter强大的技术为你代劳。它会扫描成千上万份简历，为你的职位找到绝佳匹配。Ziprecruiter让你邀请最合格的人申请你的职位，帮助你在竞争中脱颖而出。在招聘时，选择最好的。在Ziprecruiter上发布职位的五分之四雇主，都能获得优质候选人
within the first day. What are you afraid of? Go to this exclusive web address right now to try Zippercruder for free. Zippercruder.com slash smartless. Again, that's zippercruder.com slash smartlsss. Zippercruder, the smartest way to hire. And now back to the show. You know, I want to kind of give into a little bit about you and James,
在第一天内。你在害怕什么？现在就访问这个专属网址免费试用Ziprecruiter。Ziprecruiter.com斜杠smartless。再说一遍，那是ziprecruiter.com斜杠smartless。Ziprecruiter，最聪明的招聘方式。现在回到节目中。你知道，我想稍微了解一下你和詹姆斯的故事，
you got, because you guys met at such a young age, talking about like the, you know, and that you seem to still have by virtue of what you just said. You still have this like drive to like create something new and you're still excited about that creative process. What was it about that when you guys met at such a young age with coming from such different backgrounds?
你们俩，因为你们相遇时年纪那么小，谈到，你知道的，你们似乎依然凭借刚才所说的那种特质。你们仍然有着创造新事物的动力，并且对那种创作过程依然感到兴奋。当你们在那么小的年龄相遇时，考虑到背景如此不同，是什么让你们在创作上产生了共鸣？
What was the thing that clicked for you guys creatively? Yeah, because before you answer that, just to piggyback on that, I think it's fascinating. What will just said, that at such a young age, you found somebody else that wanted to take it as serious as you did. What are the odds of that? Yeah. You know? And every time people ask me that question, I always have to throw in that the energy of
是的，在你回答之前，顺着这个话题说，我觉得太迷人了。威尔刚才说的，在那么小的年龄，你找到了另一个想把它看得和你一样重要的人。这几率有多大？是啊。你知道吗？每次人们问我这个问题，我都不得不加上一句：
the universe is a big part of it because, you know, like you're saying, the two of us finding each other, you know, what we had in common, there were so many things we didn't have in common, but what we had in common was that we were both sort of loners. We were both, we weren't like outcasts in that sense or like the awkward weirdos, but we were loners and we were misfits and we were disenfranchised in a way that we just lived in our own worlds and listened to all music. When I ended up at Coral del Mar High School in 1980. Trust me, there was nobody else wearing an iron maiden t-shirt.
|宇宙的能量占了很大一部分，因为，就像你说的，我们两个找到彼此，你知道，我们的共同点，有很多我们没有共同点的地方，但我们的共同点是我们俩都有点像独行侠。我们俩，我们并不是那种被排挤的人，也不是那种尴尬的怪胎，但我们是独行侠，我们是格格不入的人，我们以某种被边缘化的方式生活在自己的世界里，听着所有的音乐。当我1980年来到卡尔德尔马高中时。相信我，没有第二个人穿铁娘子乐队的T恤。
And so it was a pretty, it was a pretty isolated existence. And so what James and I ended up doing was we were the brothers that neither of us, you know, never had. And we started writing songs together and and just creating the world for ourselves that we wanted to inhabit. And at that time there was never anything about, you know, goals or success or we're going to be, you know,
所以那是一种相当，相当孤立的生活存在。因此，詹姆斯和我最终做的事，我们成了彼此从未拥有过的兄弟。我们开始一起写歌，并为自己创造了一个我们想要栖息的世界。而在那个时候，从来没有关于，你知道的目标或成功，或者我们要成为，你知道的
famous or this is going to translate into something, you know, with the mainstream success, that there was none of that, because at that time, the music that we were into and the things that were turning us off were so edgy and so isolated away from mainstream acceptance that was never, that was never even the cards. But, you know, what's interesting about that, Laras, is that you guys were making like,
|著名人物，或者这将转化为某种，你知道的，主流成功的东西，完全没有这些，因为在那个时候，我们喜欢的音乐以及那些让我们反感的东西是如此前卫，如此远离主流的接受度，以至于那根本，那根本就不在考虑范围内。但是，你知道，关于这一点有趣的是，拉尔斯，你们当时在做的是……
you know, whatever you want to call it, hard rock, heavy metal. You guys were making like music that was really driving it and it was not necessarily mainstream. And then I think about, I think I probably went through your four records in with, by the time you guys made Metallica, which is a lot of people called the black album, by the time you guys made Metallica, you really broke through to the mainstream. You had a few hits that were kind of like leading up to it, but then the black album really broke through. And in a lot of ways I've thought before,
你知道，不管你怎么称呼它，硬摇滚、重金属。你们当时做的音乐真的很有冲击力，而且不一定是主流。然后我想想，我想我大概听了你们的四张专辑，直到你们创作了《Metallica》（很多人称之为黑色专辑）的时候，你们真正打入了主流市场。在此之前你们有几首比较热门的歌，但黑色专辑真正让你们爆红了。在很多方面，我以前常想，
I was like, is it that everybody else's tastes change or that you guys kind of, you guys prepared everybody to listen to this music. Like you guys kind of got them into this hard rock in a way. I don't know. I think you have to put the record companies in there when you answer that question. And so the record companies at that time
我在想，是所有其他人的品味变了，还是你们某种程度上，你们让大家做好了听这种音乐的准备。就像你们在某种程度上把他们带入了这种硬摇滚。我不知道。我想你在回答这个问题时，必须把唱片公司也算进去。所以当时的唱片公司
were the gateway to everything. So the record companies, it's like the analogy of said many times is that you walk into a restaurant and you can have anything that you want in the restaurant as long as it's on the menu. The record companies were the purveyors of the menu and so the record companies were only signing things that they thought would appeal to a large group of people. But hovering over in the left field were all these people like ourselves that wanted something that would anxieties and issues just like ourselves. And so slowly over the 80s, as more and more kids understood that they were music out there for them,
是通往一切的门户。所以唱片公司，就像人们多次比喻的那样，你走进一家餐厅，只要菜单上有，你想点什么都可以。唱片公司就是菜单的提供者，所以唱片公司只签下他们认为能吸引大量人群的东西。但在左外野盘旋着的，是我们这样的一群人，他们想要一些能表达焦虑和问题的东西，就像我们自己一样。因此，在整个80年代，随着越来越多的孩子意识到有这样的音乐适合他们，
like the type of stuff that we were doing, they started moving further and further, left. They started moving the mainstream further and further out to where bands like ourselves were hovering. And there was that seismic shift then towards the late 80s when all of a sudden, the mainstream realized that there were other options that they had been fed over the years. Right. And you guys were like you said, lyrically, Sean, that way, and I don't know, lards, if you heard me before you came on, I quoted your song one. And I said, you know, take my brothers, I pray for death. uh, uh, you know, take my brothers. I pray for death.
就像我们做的那种音乐，他们开始越来越向左发展。他们把主流推得越来越远，推到了像我们这样的乐队盘旋的地方。然后在80年代末，发生了一次震撼性的转变，当时主流突然意识到，除了多年来被强行灌输的选择之外，他们还有别的选择。对的。正如你所说，肖恩，你们在歌词上就是这样的，我不知道，拉尔斯，你在上节目之前有没有听到我引用你们的歌《One》。我说过，你知道，带走我的兄弟们，我祈求死亡。呃，呃，你知道，带走我的兄弟们，我祈求死亡。
Oh God, please take it. I did. Yeah. And like that, I didn't write that one down as a potential, but no, I know. I have the other ones. Well, you already have that song. That song already exists as a hit. And it's like, it's still hard to beat bread balls.
哦，天哪，请带走它吧。我确实这么做了。对。就像那个，我没有把它当作潜在的曲目写下来，不过，不，我知道。我有其他的。好吧，你们已经有那首歌了。那首歌作为热门单曲已经存在了。而且这就像，还是很难超越贝雷帽。
But that song is like, I mean, you think about you guys that, I mean, that song specifically is about a guy who's basically in a calmer right, he's kind of paralyzed, or what's the deal with that? Like, nobody was writing songs about that and everything. We spent a lot of time, we spent a lot of time sort of wondering what, you know, different mental states. And so at one point we were talking about what would be like
但那首歌就像，我的意思是，想想你们，我的意思是，那首歌具体是关于一个基本上成了植物人的家伙，对吧，他有点瘫痪了，或者说这是怎么回事？就像，没有人写过关于这种事的歌。我们花了很多时间，我们花了很多时间来琢磨，你知道，不同的精神状态。所以有一次我们在讨论，如果
if you couldn't speak, see or or hear and you had no arms or legs But you were just a living conscious. What would that feel like? What what would go on inside you if you were just a living conscious? And then we found out about Dalton Trumbull's story of Johnny Gartis gun and then We wrote a song around that and then realized that there was actually a movie with Jason Robards that came out, I think, what, late 60s, early 70s. And that became our first video. And that was a four albums in. And at that time, we had never made any videos for MTV. And we were sort of the anti-MTV band, but we finally felt that we had an idea
你不能说话、看或听，也没有胳膊或腿，但你只是一个有意识的活人，那会是什么感觉？如果你只是一个活着的意识，你内心会发生什么？然后我们发现了道尔顿·特姆博的故事《强尼上战场》，然后我们围绕这个写了一首歌，后来发现实际上有一部由杰森·罗巴兹主演的电影，我想是在，什么，60年代末、70年代初上映的。那成了我们的第一支音乐录影带。那是出到第四张专辑的时候。当时，我们从来没有为MTV制作过任何录影带。我们算是一支反MTV乐队，但我们最终觉得我们有一个想法
that was worthy of making a video. And you guys remember something called dial MTV back or day. So the first day that that video premiered and was eligible for dial MTV had premiered at number one and it stayed at number one for like the next couple of months. And that was a significant, I think, a wake-up call to a lot of the industry,
值得拍成一支MV。你们还记得以前有个叫拨打MTV的东西吗？所以那支MV首播的那天，并且符合拨打MTV的资格，它首播就登上了第一名，并且在接下来的几个月里一直保持在第一名。我认为这对很多业内人士来说是一个重大的警钟，
them realizing that there was something else out there than I don't wanna mention names, but that that was out there at that time that was generating a lot of the attention. Something more than Frankie goes to Hollywood with the lasers. Way to go, JB. I mean, well, the dancing all around it. Do you miss videos at all?
让他们意识到，除了我不想点名、但当时确实存在的、吸引了大量关注的那些东西之外，还有别的东西存在。比带有激光的“好莱坞弗兰基”更强大的东西。干得好，JB。我的意思是，到处都在跳舞。你一点也不怀念MV吗？
We still make videos. We made for a new album. Now it's actually the opposite for the last two records we put out. We've made videos for every song on them because if you now, you know, so many people here, albums on YouTube, so you want to have a video that you've made yourself for every song on your album rather than having somebody else make them. So we've made videos for every song in the last album that just came out a few days ago. I love that. I remember long, long time ago, I don't remember the year, but just when you're dead. This is when you're dead. When my dad left, yeah, it was 1975. No.
我们还在制作MV。我们为新专辑制作了。现在实际上正好相反，对于我们发行的最后两张专辑。我们为上面的每一首歌都制作了MV，因为如果你现在，你知道，有那么多人在YouTube上听专辑，所以你希望为专辑中的每一首歌都拥有一支自己制作的MV，而不是让别人来制作。所以我们为刚刚在几天前发行的上一张专辑里的每一首歌都制作了MV。我喜欢这样。我记得很久很久以前，我不记得是哪一年了，但就在你爸爸去世的时候。这是在你爸爸去世的时候。当我爸爸离开的时候，对，那是1975年。不。
Do you have a question for my dad? I'm trying to drive and just light up the rear positraction and go. No, I have a question. You know, just like, just like Metallica, they turn professional one day. You guys should do this. We will try to do it.
你有什么问题要问我爸爸吗？我正开着车，只想点亮后轮牵引力然后出发。不，我有一个问题。你知道，就像，就像Metallica一样，他们有一天变得专业了。你们也该这么做。我们会尽量做到的。
No, I remember when hearing about you doing a concert in Antarctica, right? That's right. I was the only band who's played on all seven continents. It was sort of by chance. It was not something that we set out to do. Well, I don't think one would. But yeah. No, but it's not like you sit there and go, Hey, what should we do this year? Let's play all seven continents.
不，我记得听说你们在南极洲开演唱会，对吧？是的。我是唯一一支在所有七大洲都演出过的乐队。这有点像是个巧合。这不是我们刻意要去完成的事情。好吧，我想不会有人这么刻意。但是是的。不，但这并不意味着你坐在那里说：“嘿，我们今年该做点什么？去所有七大洲演出吧。”
We were playing in Latin America. We were playing in Europe. We were playing in North America. We had shows in, you know, in Africa and Asia and all of a sudden it was like, whoa, there's a thing happening here. And we got an offer from, I believe it was Coca-Cola. It was soft drink in Brazil,
我们在拉丁美洲演出。我们在欧洲演出。我们在北美演出。我们在，你知道，非洲和亚洲也有演出，突然之间就觉得，哇，这里正在发生一件大事。我们接到了一个邀请，我相信是可口可乐公司发出的。那是巴西的一款软饮料，
who said that they were putting together a competition. And the prize was to travel to an article and hang out and they wanted to know if we would come down and play for this group of soft drinkers. Was it cold? Well, it was December, which is their June, which is their high summer. And it wasn't as cold and it wasn't as frigid
他们说正在组织一场比赛。奖品是去南极洲旅行并四处逛逛，他们想知道我们是否愿意下来为这群喝软饮料的人演出。冷吗？嗯，那是12月，也就是他们的6月，也就是他们的盛夏。它没有那么冷，也没有那么严寒，
and it wasn't as sort of otherworldly as you would expect it to be. Yeah, because I was gonna say, how do your hands work? But we were down there for a couple of four or five days. We stayed on an icebreaker and we stayed with all the contest winners and all our crew were all on this icebreaker together
也没有你想象的那么超凡脱俗。是的，因为我本来想说，你们的手怎么还能弹奏？但我们在那里待了大约四五天。我们住在一艘破冰船上，我们和所有的比赛获胜者住在一起，我们所有的工作人员都一起在这艘破冰船上，
which was super fun. And then we played on a Chilean research base and we played in a tent. And you guys know what Silent Disco is? No, we were already very busy. So every, exactly, everybody had headphones on. So the, I think there were like maybe 300 people there and total everybody had headphones on, so they could hear the music.
这超级有趣。然后我们在一个智利的科考基地演出，我们在一个帐篷里演出。你们知道什么是无声迪斯科吗？不，我们当时已经非常忙了。所以每个人，没错，每个人都戴着耳机。所以，我想那里大概有300人左右，总共每个人都戴着耳机，这样他们就能听到音乐。
And so it didn't disturb the environment. It didn't disturb the penguins. It didn't disturb the other endangered species of animals that were there. And so we left no, there was not even, not even noise pollution. It's weird I last summer I was in New York and I saw these kids like late night and they're all in the steps of this church like midnight on a Friday night and everybody's moving
所以它没有打扰到那里的环境。它没有打扰到企鹅。它没有打扰到那里的其他濒危动物。所以我们没有留下任何东西，甚至连噪音污染都没有。奇怪的是，去年夏天我在纽约，我看到这些孩子在深夜，大概周五午夜，都坐在一个教堂的台阶上，每个人都在动，
nobody's saying a word and I realize they've all got headphones on they're all jamming and they're all dancing to the song but you can't exactly the only thing you can hear in the room are the lead vocals and the drums. Other than that, all the amplified instruments are going through the headphones. So it was definitely a mind-fuck to be down there, a lot of fun and to answer your question.
没有人说一句话。我意识到他们都戴着耳机，他们都在即兴演奏，都随着音乐跳舞，但你听不到——确切地说，在这个房间里你能听到的唯一声音就是主唱和鼓声。除此之外，所有放大的乐器声音都是通过耳机传出的。所以身处那里绝对是一次震撼大脑的体验，非常有趣，回答你的问题。
It wasn't as crazy cold or as fucked up as you would imagine it to be. But it was cool. Well, I want to go back to James just for one second. Just talk about collaboration and sort of sharing power and creativity and not just with him, but with the rest of the band mates. I mean, you guys have been together and so successful and so harmonious, no pun intended for so long. Is there a secret sauce to that?
它并不像你想象的那么疯狂地寒冷或糟糕。但它很酷。嗯，我想把话题拉回詹姆斯身上哪怕一秒钟。谈谈合作，以及分享权力和创造力，不仅是和他，还有乐队的其他成员。我的意思是，你们在一起这么久，取得了如此巨大的成功，如此和谐（双关语就不开了）。这其中有什么秘诀吗？
I'm sure there's some good leadership involved. Yeah, I would say the probably the word compromise. Sure. You gotta learn to compromise. You gotta learn to know and to lead and you gotta learn when to step back. James and I have been obviously in the band since the beginning and we, I guess, we steer most of the creative conversations and we take turns steering and I think compromise is the key thing. And if you want to be in a band in your 50s and 60s,
我确信这其中有一些很好的领导力。是的，我想说这个词可能是“妥协”。当然。你得学会妥协。你得学会什么时候该做主、什么时候该领导，你得学会什么时候退居幕后。詹姆斯和我显然从一开始就在乐队里，我们，我猜，我们掌控着大部分的创作对话，我们轮流掌舵，我认为妥协是关键所在。如果你想在50岁和60岁时还呆在乐队里，
and really want to be in a band, you've got to learn to sort of work with the environment of sort of how to deal with everybody's personal needs. The reason that there is millions of bands how to deal with everybody's personal needs. The reason that there is millions of bands of people in their teens and 20s and fewer bands of people in their 50s and 60s is, you know, when people get older, they just don't wanna deal
并且真心想呆在乐队里，你必须学会如何适应那种如何处理每个人个人需求的氛围。之所以有成百上千个由十几岁和二十几岁年轻人组成的乐队，而50岁和60岁的人组成的乐队却很少，你知道，当人们变老时，他们就是不想去应付
with other people's shit. And you don't wanna compromise and you don't wanna, hey, I've got, you know, my son's graduation is the week of Lala Palusa. Oh, well, I guess we can't play Lala Palusa or whatever. So there's a lot of those types of conversations that take place. And we have a thing in our band where everybody gets a chance
别人的烂摊子。你不想妥协，你不想说：“嘿，你知道，我儿子的毕业典礼和Lollapalooza音乐节在同一周。”哦，好吧，我想我们不能去Lollapalooza了，诸如此类。所以会有很多这种类型的对话发生。我们在乐队里有一个规定，每个人都有机会
to, you know, black dates out and put, you know, exes in a calendar and that can't be challenged. We're very supportive of each other's personal space. And we, you know, we put more resources and time into sort of the whole thing functioning as a band than we ever have before. And I'm not going to bullshit you. I mean, that doesn't get any easier as you get older now Most of the kids are grown up and and you know off to college or in their 20s So there's less concerns about getting home, but we you know we I mean 10 years ago we were tour in two-week increments
你知道，把日期涂黑，在日历上打上叉子，这是不容置疑的。我们非常支持彼此的个人空间。而且我们，你知道，比起以往任何时候，我们投入更多的资源和时间来确保整个乐队作为一个整体运转。我不会对你胡扯的。我的意思是，随着年龄的增长，这并没有变得更容易，现在大多数孩子都长大了，去上大学了或者二十多岁了。所以回家照顾孩子的担忧少了，但是我们，你知道，我的意思是，十年前我们是按两周为一个周期进行巡演的。
We would go on the road for two weeks go home for two weeks, you know go on the road for two weeks, go home for two weeks, you know, go on the road for two weeks, go home for two weeks. So we wouldn't miss, you know, being with our kids and all that stuff. It's gonna ask you about that about family. I mean, you guys must have had some very supportive and flexible families throughout all the way. Yeah, but we've also steered it in the direction of trying to keep all that, you know, as together as possible.
我们会出门巡演两周，回家两周，你知道，出门巡演两周，回家两周，你知道，出门巡演两周，回家两周。这样我们就不会错过陪伴孩子和所有这些事情。我正要问你关于家庭的事。我的意思是，一路走来，你们一定拥有非常支持你们且灵活变通的家人。是的，但我们也一直在努力把所有这些，你知道的，尽可能凝聚在一起。
I'm sure it's the same with you guys, but you know, in our world, it takes a few years before you realize that you actually have a say in some of this. Yeah. When you start out, you just get handed a schedule there's like, and when you're 22 years old, hey, I just want to play as many gigs as possible
我确信你们也是一样，但在我们的世界里，要花好几年时间你才会意识到，其实你在其中的一些事情上是有发言权的。是的。当你刚开始的时候，你只是拿到一份日程表，上面写着，当你22岁的时候，嘿，我只想尽可能多地演出，
and travel as much as be as drunk as possible and get into all kinds of crazy shenanigans. But then you realize later, hang on a second, I can actually say, I only want to be on the road for three months, and then I want to spend three months at home. Or, you know, so, you know, as you go along and become more successful, you realize it, you have a saying this stuff.
尽可能多地旅行，尽可能喝得烂醉如泥，然后卷入各种疯狂的恶作剧。但后来你意识到，等一下，我其实可以表态，我只想在路上待三个月，然后我想在家待三个月。或者，你知道，随着你不断前行并取得更大成功，你会意识到，在这件事上你是有发言权的。
Well, we're lucky because we started doing, certainly we started doing this thing in our 50s. And as we've done, and we've talked about maybe, you know, we went on, we did a short two or a couple years ago and we're talking about doing another one. But everything that we do, we always do with the understanding that like everybody's got stuff, and if somebody's got stuff, we never challenge it in that same way either because we know what life's like and it's kids and it's thing
好吧，我们很幸运，因为我们开始做这件事的时候，当然是在我们50多岁的时候。正如我们所做的那样，我们曾讨论过，你知道，我们在几年前进行了一次短途巡演，我们正在商量再来一次。但我们所做的每一件事，都始终带着这样的共识：每个人都有自己的事，如果某人有事，我们也绝不会以那种方式去质疑，因为我们知道生活是什么样的，有孩子，有各种事情，
and it's Sean's been doing his play for six months and like that's important. So we've got to honor that and that's a thing you got to do. I forgot to ask, because I've always wanted to know this. Favorite color? No, I was to ask, because I always wanted to know this. Favorite color? I think I was gonna, I was gonna, I was gonna, I was gonna, I was gonna, I was gonna, I was gonna, I was gonna, I was gonna,
还有肖恩一直在排练他的戏剧已经六个月了，这很重要。所以我们必须尊重这一点，这是你必须要做的事情。我忘了问，因为我一直想知道这个。最喜欢的颜色？不，我要问的是，因为我一直想知道这个。最喜欢的颜色？我想我会，我会，我会，我会，我会，我会，我会，我会，我会，
I know that Sean was letting up. Favorite advertiser on the Chin Chin menu. No, no, no, no. What was, what's your favorite? Dipping sauce for the- Who came up with Metallica? No, Metallica, we're that kind of- Don't play Dipping Sauce.
我知道肖恩要让步了。最喜欢的“金金”菜单上的广告商。不，不，不，不。什么是，你最喜欢的是什么？蘸酱用来——谁想出了Metallica这个名字？不，Metallica，我们是那种——别玩蘸酱的梗。
The name? Yeah, man. Ron Quintana. Ron Quintana. Ron Quintana was a friend of mine at San Francisco. Up in San Francisco, there was a little bit of a different music scene than an LA when we started, and we started playing up in San Francisco early, and we had some friends up there
名字？对，老兄。罗恩·金塔纳。罗恩·金塔纳。罗恩·金塔纳是我的一个朋友，在旧金山。在旧金山，当我们刚开始时，那里的音乐场景和洛杉矶有点不同，我们很早就开始在旧金山演出，我们在那儿有一些朋友，
and so on, but one of the guys up there, Ron Quintana, he, back then, pre-internet, pre- you know, all this stuff, you know, if you wanted information about your favorite bands, you had to, you know, write to pen pals or, you know, and everybody, everybody that was really into music at the time made their own fan scenes, as they were called. So it was eight pages, stable together down at Kingco's about whatever their favorite French heavy metal band that five people had heard of was into. And so Ron Quintana wanted to start a little fan magazine. And he asked me one day whether he should call it Metal Mania
诸如此类。但那儿的一个家伙，罗恩·金塔纳，他在当时互联网出现之前、你知道所有这些东西出现之前，如果你想了解你最喜欢的乐队的信息，你必须，你知道，写信给笔友，或者，你知道，而且每一个当时真正热爱音乐的人都会制作他们自己的歌迷杂志，正如它们被称为的那样。所以那是用订书机在Kinko's钉在一起的八页纸，内容是关于他们最喜欢的、只有五个人听说过的法国重金属乐队。所以罗恩·金塔纳想办一本小型歌迷杂志。他有一天问我，他是应该叫它《金属狂热》
or whether he should call it Metallica. And I told him to call it Metal Mania. And we're taking Metallica. I'll hang onto the Metallica for you. And so I've been forgiven that. Thankfully a long time ago and Ron is still a good friend. It's cool. It's a fucking, it's a rad name.
还是应该叫它《Metallica》。我告诉他叫《金属狂热》。我们要用《Metallica》。我把《Metallica》这个名字留给你。所以，谢天谢地，很久以前我就被原谅了，罗恩现在仍然是个好朋友。这很酷。这真是个他妈的、超棒的名字。
It's good. Feels good on my tongue. So Lars, this is the stand shot. Oh, I'm sure you're done. Hey, Sean. Sorry to subject you to my dumb question here, but I asked, but I use my favorite answer. God, again, Lars, we're so sick.
很好。在我的舌头上感觉很好。所以，拉尔斯，这是标准镜头。哦，我确信你已经说完了。嘿，肖恩。很抱歉让你听我这愚蠢的问题，但我问了，但我用了我最喜欢的回答。天哪，又来了，拉尔斯，我们太厌烦了。
I'm a city to play in. Isn't it cold playing without your top on? No. Sure. No, I don't know. Reef's not. Reef's not. Reef's not. Why is your hand always backwards?
一个适合演出的城市。光着上身演出不是很冷吗？不。当然。不，我不知道。里夫没有。里夫没有。里夫没有。为什么你的手总是反着长？
What's going on? You don't want to see what lives under here trust me. Oh, what doesn't live under there? I want another craziest tourist story, like fan weirdness. There's something that went wrong on stage or during a set or like you got to have something that just was like, oh God, the worst one of all was blank. Well, we're very lucky.
怎么回事？相信我，你不会想看这里面住着什么东西的。哦，这里面住的都是什么呀？我想听另一个最疯狂的巡演故事，比如歌迷的怪异举动。有没有什么在舞台上或演出期间出了差错的事情，或者说你肯定经历过那种让人觉得“哦天哪，最糟糕的一次是空白”的事情。好吧，我们很幸运。
I'll answer both. We're very lucky in that we have an incredible group of people that follow us pretty much wherever we go. We actually started selling tickets to them. On the last tour, we have something called a black ticket. So you can buy now a ticket that gets you into all the shows on a tour. And so there's, uh, there's, uh, hundreds, if not thousands of people, you know, we'll go out and play for, you know, six, eight weeks in Europe, order.
我两个都回答。我们非常幸运，能拥有一群不可思议的人，无论我们走到哪里，他们几乎都会一路追随。我们实际上开始向他们出售门票。在上一场巡演中，我们有一种叫“黑色门票”的东西。所以你现在可以买到一张能让你进入巡演所有场次的门票。所以有，呃，有，呃，成百上千甚至上万人，你知道，我们会去演出，你知道，在欧洲待上六、八周，按计划进行。
And it's, you know, we see all the same faces down front. No, so passionate and they come from all over from Latin America, from Asia, from Europe. So we have the black tickets. What's that black ticket running, Lars? Yeah. Yeah. The black ticket. Well, I know people, if you're interested, Jason, and you want to come out, it runs,
而且，你知道，在前排我们总是看到那些熟悉的面孔。不，他们太热情了，他们来自世界各地，从拉丁美洲、亚洲到欧洲。所以我们有黑色门票。那张黑色门票多少钱，拉尔斯？对。对。黑色门票。嗯，我知道有人，如果你有兴趣，杰森，你想去的话，它的价格是——
uh, it's got to be some kind of a break on it, right? 800, that's, what? That's a big break. Yeah. There's a big break. That's nothing. Uh, it's, uh's for all those shows. We tried to be his fan for. How much did he say?
呃，这肯定得有什么折扣吧？800美元，那是，什么？这是一个很大的折扣。对。这是一个很大的折扣。这不算什么。呃，它是，呃，适用于所有这些演出。我们尽量对粉丝好。他说多少钱？
How much did he say? $800. You can see all the shows in the entire tour. Fucking way. Now they don't get to jump on the plane. I don't get to jump on the plane. No, but I'm going to buy for I'm going to buy for all of us. Fuck, Lars. I'm going to get you one too. Yeah. You know what though? I wish'd had that, you know, I saw you guys. So, Lars, I saw you in Guns and Roses in September of 1992 at C.N.E. Canadian National Expression Stadium in Toronto. It was one of the fucking great concerts. All right. I'm in. It was unfuck in real. I was 22. Sure. And you guys rocked it out. And I have such a vivid memory of you. Got it. And even
他说多少钱？800美元。你可以观看整场巡演的所有演出。他妈的真的假的。现在他们可不能跟着跳上飞机。我可不能跟着跳上飞机。不，不过我要买，我要给我们所有人都买一张。操，拉尔斯。我也给你买一张。你知道吗，不过？我真希望当时有这个，你知道，我见过你们。所以，拉尔斯，我在1992年9月在多伦多的C.N.E.（加拿大国家展览体育场）看过你和枪炮与玫瑰的演出。那是他妈的棒极了的演唱会之一。好吧。我加入了。那真是太他妈不真实了。我当时22岁。确实如此。你们把全场都摇滚起来了。我对你有着如此生动的记忆。懂了。甚至
what it was basically every song you guys played. And everybody in Unison rocking out, I've never seen it. I've never seen anything like it before or since, in the way the dedication and the sort of the rhythmic unison. It's very, very, very past religious stuff. Your eyeballs have seen from your position. You get to see the whole band in front of you
基本上是你们演奏的每一首歌。每个人都异口同声地摇滚起来，我从来没见过。我以前或以后都从未见过这样的景象，那种奉献精神和那种节奏上的齐声呼应。这是非常非常非常具有宗教色彩的东西。从你的位置，你的眼睛能够看到
and then all of the people in the crowd. Dude, I'm telling you, it's bizarre. It was fucking images you have in your head must be. We're also now, I'll circle back to the question, the Chani was asking earlier and I'll give you a variation in what you just said about seeing all the people in front of me. So you talk about malfunctions. The first one that always comes to mind
你面前的整个乐队，以及观众席里的所有人。老兄，我告诉你，这太诡异了。那种在你脑海中的画面一定——我们现在也，我转回恰尼刚才问的问题，并对你刚才说的关于看到我面前所有人的话做一个变通。所以你们谈到设备故障。我脑海中总是浮现出的第一个故障，
because it left a deep, deep scar. You were talking about the black album will. And so we were touring on the black album, which was our most successful record, up till then. And we had been in America for maybe a year, year and a half. We'd done the guns and roses tour and we were starting in Europe a few months later and we were playing in London and at that time and obviously still you know London is just press and business and peers and you know publicity and all the
因为它留下了深深的、深深的伤疤。你刚才谈到了黑色专辑，威尔。所以我们当时正在为黑色专辑进行巡演，这是我们迄今为止最成功的唱片。我们在美国呆了大约一年、一年半。我们做完了枪炮与玫瑰的巡演，几个月后我们将在欧洲开始巡演，我们在伦敦演出，当时——显然现在也是——伦敦到处都是媒体、商业、同行、声誉、宣传，还有所有的
all the you know people from all from all the record companies and all the publicists and everybody from all of Europe are there. It's London and at that time it's all music magazines and weekly, like the enemy and Karrang and blah, blah, blah. And so we're playing in the round, which we still do. And I have a drum kit on either side of the stage, and halfway through the set, I'm supposed to run over,
那些来自各个唱片公司、所有公关人员以及来自全欧洲的所有人都在那里。这是伦敦，当时那里的所有音乐杂志都是周刊，比如《NME》和《Kerrang》等等。所以我们在圆形舞台上演出，我们现在依然这么做。我在舞台的两侧各有一套架子鼓，演到演出中途时，我得跑过去，
and then the other drum kit, I'm supposed to sit on the other drum kit as it lifts out of the stage, and then I play the other half of the show over on the other side. We could probably guess what happened. So this is the first big show of this European tour. Everybody in our universe is there. And so the drum kit, you know, under the stage, I'm on the drum kit and it won't fucking lift up out of the stage. So my view is not 20,000 crazy
然后在另一套架子鼓上，当它从舞台升起时，我应该坐在另一套架子鼓上，然后我在另一侧演奏完剩下的半场演出。我们大概能猜到发生了什么。所以这是这次欧洲巡演的第一场大型演出。我们世界里的所有人都到了。所以那套架子鼓，你知道，在舞台底下，我在架子鼓上，它他妈的就是不肯从舞台上升起来。所以我看到的景象不是温布利体育馆里20,000名疯狂的
people in Wembley Arena, wherever it was. It's all the nuts and bolts and the steel and the 12 roadies that are down under the stage with like crowbars and fucking screwdrivers and hammers or whatever they're trying to do and they're trying to get this thing to lift up out of the stage. I ended up playing like a song in a half underground.
观众，无论那是在哪里。我看到的全都是螺母、螺栓、钢铁，以及12名舞台工作人员，他们拿着撬棍、他妈的螺丝刀、锤子或者诸如此类的东西在舞台底下试图搞定它，他们正试图让这玩意儿从舞台上升起来。我最后在地下弹了一首半的歌。
Under the stage submerged, just sitting there. And as Metallica was supposed to have all these articles written about the triumphant return back to Europe after three years after being the biggest rock band in America. The whole story was just about Larsus fucking drums that didn't want to lift out of the stage. Welcome back to Europe. Thank you very much. That's great. I love that. That is so great.
在舞台底下被淹没着，就坐在那儿。而Metallica本该写满各种报道，讲述在作为全美最大的摇滚乐队三年后，凯旋重返欧洲的故事。整个故事却全都是关于拉尔斯他妈的打捞不起来的架子鼓。欢迎回到欧洲。非常感谢。太棒了。我喜欢这样。这真是太棒了。
And so... So, what did you finish the rest on the other drum set? The rest of the show on the other. And eventually, with enough crowbars and determination, the drums ended up on stage where they belonged. That's good. We'll be right back. up on stage with their belong. That's good.
所以……那么，你在另一套架子鼓上完成了剩下的演出吗？剩下的演出都在另一套上。最终，凭借足够的撬棍和决心，架子鼓终于回到了它该在的舞台上。很好。我们马上回来。回到它该在的舞台上。很好。
We'll be right back. Smilest is supported by state farm insurance can be confusing sometimes. That's why state farm is there for your what-ifs because they know the rest of your life is already full of thinking about other things like what if your life was a playlist. Imagine how crazy it would be. Your first song might be a noisy track called Kids, a second one, a spooky track called Home Ownership, then like a hundred more songs called Work, a second one, a spooky track called Home Ownership, then like a hundred more songs called Work, Health,
我们马上回来。Smilest节目由State Farm保险赞助，保险有时会让人感到困惑。这就是为什么State Farm会为你的“万一”保驾护航，因为他们知道你的余生已经充满了对其他事情的思考，比如“如果你的生活是一个播放列表”。想象一下会有多疯狂。你的第一首歌可能是一首名为《孩子们》的嘈杂歌曲，第二首是一首名为《拥有房屋》的诡异歌曲，然后大约有一百多首名为《工作》的歌曲，第二首是一首名为《拥有房屋》的诡异歌曲，然后还有大约一百多首名为《工作》的歌曲，还有健康、
Pat, Cars, Yardwork, the playlist goes on. And once you put it on repeat and add shuffle mode, things might not sound all that jazzy. That's why the last track you'd wanna add to your life's playlist is called Insurance Uncertainties, with lyrics like, what if I'd like to add coverage to my policy? What if I have a question at 3 a.m.?
宠物、汽车、院子里的活儿，播放列表还在继续。一旦你把它设为循环播放并加上随机播放模式，事情听起来可能就不会那么美妙了。这就是为什么你最不想加入你生活播放列表的最后一首歌叫做“保险不确定性”，它的歌词像是：如果我想在我的保单中增加保障会怎样？如果我在凌晨3点有问题怎么办？
Well, there are some positive notes that can help keep your life in harmony. You can file a claim on the State Farm mobile app, talk to a real person, including your agent, and you can call day or night about insurance coverage and policy questions because that's just what they do. So no matter how noise
好吧，有一些积极的音符可以帮助你的生活保持和谐。你可以在State Farm手机应用程序上提交理赔申请，与真人对话，包括你的代理人，并且你可以日夜致电咨询保险范围和保单问题，因为这正是他们所做的。所以无论你的生活变得多么嘈杂，
your life may get insurance can still be music to your ears like a good neighbor state farm is there call or go to state farm dot com for a quote today. Hey smart list listener. This episode is brought to you
保险仍然可以成为你耳中的美妙音乐。就像好邻居一样，State Farm就在身边。今天就打电话或访问statefarm.com获取报价吧。嘿，SmartLess的听众。本集由
and part by fan duel. Score early this with fan dual america's number because right now new cust dollars in bonus bets, g play say $5 bet. That's $150 in bonus bets win or lose. There's no better time to get
FanDuel部分赞助。在FanDuel提前得分，这是全美第一的博彩公司，因为现在新客户只需下注5美元，即可获得150美元的奖励投注，无论输赢。没有比现在更好的时机来加入了。
is so easy to use. There's a wide range of betting options, including spreads, player props, overunders, and more. Now, I'm trying to get them to book a bet for me on how long Sean Hayes will stay a part of SmartLess. They're saying the odds are so small that they just can't find anyone to balance out the other side of it. So I've moved on to Will Arnett,
它是如此易于使用。有广泛的投注选项，包括让分盘、球员道具投注、大小盘等等。现在，我正试图让他们为我下一注关于肖恩·海耶斯会继续留在SmartLess多久的赌注。他们说赔率太小了，以至于他们根本找不到任何人来平衡另一边的赌注。所以我转向了威尔·阿奈特，
still getting really long odds on him staying longer than maybe the next couple of weeks. But anyway, they will take most bets on things I think over there at FanDuel. So visit fandual.com slash smartlisten kickoff the NFL season fan duel, official partner of the NFL. 21 plus exclusions apply, C show notes for full disclaimer.
关于他能留得比接下来的几周更久，依然能得到非常高的赔率。不管怎样，我想那边的大多数关于各种事情的赌注他们都会接的。所以请访问fandual.com/smartlisten，开启NFL赛季。FanDuel，NFL官方合作伙伴。21岁以上，适用排除条款，完整免责声明请参见节目说明。
We get support from NetSuite by Oracle. Your business was humming, but now you're falling behind. Teams buried in manual work, taking forever to close the books, getting one source of truth is like pulling teeth. If this is you, you should know these three numbers. 36,025, one. 36,000, that's the number of businesses which have upgraded to NetSuite by Oracle.
我们得到了Oracle旗下NetSuite的支持。你的业务曾经运转良好，但现在你落后了。团队埋头于手工琐事，结账耗时漫长，要获取单一真实的信源简直难如登天。如果这就是你的现状，你应该记住这三个数字：36,025, 1。36,000，这是升级到Oracle旗下NetSuite的企业数量。
NetSuite is the number one cloud financial system, streamlining, accounting, financial management, inventory, HR, and more. 25, NetSuite turns 25 this year. That's 25 years of helping businesses do more with less. Close their books in days, not weeks and drive down costs. One, because your business is one of a kind. So you get a customized solution for all your KPIs in one efficient system with one source of truth. Manage risk, get reliable forecasts, and improve margins.
NetSuite是排名第一的云端财务系统，能够简化会计、财务管理、库存、人力资源等等。25，NetSuite今年迎来了25周年。那是帮助企业以更少投入实现更多成效的25年。在几天内而不是几周内完成结账，并降低成本。1，因为你的业务是独一无二的。所以你可以在一个高效的系统中，通过单一真实的信源，为你的所有KPI获得定制化的解决方案。管理风险，获得可靠的预测，并提高利润率。
Everything you need all in one place. I mean, since when has everything you need all in one place ever been a bad thing, right? That's the greatest thing. Right now, download NetSweets Popular KPI checklist designed to give you consistently excellent performance, absolutely free at netsweep.com slash smartless. That's netsweep.com slash smartless to get your own KPI checklist.
你需要的一切都在一个地方。我的意思是，自从什么时候起，你需要的一切都在一个地方变成了一件坏事，对吧？这是最棒的事情。现在，就在netsweep.com/smartless免费下载NetSuite广受欢迎的KPI检查清单，旨在为你提供始终如一的卓越表现。访问netsweep.com/smartless即可获取你自己的KPI检查清单。
Netsweep.com slash smartless. And back to the show. Are you excited by anybody right now that you're comfortable saying that has sort of the same kind of early ambition that you guys had to sort of be a little left or a little right of what is being embraced, you know, that sort of real mainstream. You guys are really courageous by kind of pushing the envelope. Is there somebody in music right now that you're excited about their courage? I mean, there's a lot of great people in garages and in bedrooms all over, obviously,
Netsweep.com/smartless。让我们回到节目中。现在有没有哪个人让你感到兴奋，并且让你愿意承认他们身上有着和你们当年一样的那种早期雄心，想要稍微偏离主流一点点，或者稍微站在主流正在拥抱的事物的左边或右边，那种真正的传统主流？你们通过不断突破界限展现了巨大的勇气。现在音乐界有没有谁的勇气让你感到兴奋？显然，到处都有很多优秀的音乐人待在车库里和卧室里，
making records on their computers now that don't need to go into studios and do the whole, the whole spiel that everybody had to do 20, 30 years ago. They don't have to rely on record companies. I think an artist like Billy Eilish, you know, what her and her brother did a couple years ago, those first records that were made at home on the computers is crazy cool and is so, it sort of epitomizes, you know, the shift of, you need a record contract and you need half a million bucks
现在他们在电脑上制作唱片，不需要像20、30年前每个人那样走进录音室去搞那一整套流程。他们不必依赖唱片公司。我认为像比利·艾利什这样的艺人，你知道，她和她哥哥几年前做的事情，那些在家里的电脑上制作的第一张唱片是疯狂的酷，并且非常完美地体现了，你知道这种转变：你不再需要唱片合同，也不需要50万美元
to go into a proper studio and make a record now. And they made those first couple of records just at home on their computers. And that to me, it's indicative of the possibilities now that the technology, the four of us could make a record for the rest of the possibilities now that the technology, you know, the four of us could make a record for the rest of the afternoon and put it out tomorrow. Let's do it.
去一个正规的录音室做一张唱片了。他们仅仅在家里用电脑就制作了前几张唱片。对我来说，这象征着现在技术带来的可能性，我们四个人可以在今天剩下的时间里制作一张唱片，明天就能发布。我们干吧。
Jesus, where are we not doing this? Where are we not doing this? Why are we not doing this right? Fucking now, Lauren, do we want to break the internet or not? What are we doing? Well, speak a little bit more about that, about the record industry and stuff, not not to get sort of in the weeds about all that, but, you know, obviously there's been a
天哪，我们为什么不这么做？我们为什么不这么做？为什么我们现在不这么做？老兄，拉尔斯，我们是想引爆互联网还是不想？我们在干什么？好吧，再多谈谈那个，关于唱片行业之类的事情，不是要深入讨论所有这些琐事，但是，你知道，显然唱片行业已经发生了
big, a big, big change in the record industry were streaming, etc. Yeah, and you're not really selling albums as much as more of kind of all a cart kind of songs that are downloaded on streamers, and then the bands really make their money curriculum if I'm wrong from touring now. And so I'm assuming that the bands, if they want to make money, they got to be on the road more. Are you guys on the road more? You guys don't need to make money. But how are you, how are you feeling about the way the, the business is sort of balanced right now as far as being out versus selling album, staying home and the, the, the, the ratio of that? Well, obviously it's changed quite a bit.
巨大、巨大、巨大的变化，比如流媒体等等。是的，你们卖专辑不再像以前那么多了，更多的是在流媒体上下载那种点菜式的单曲，然后乐队真正赚钱的途径——如果我错了请纠正我——现在是从巡演中赚钱。所以我假设乐队如果想赚钱，就得更多地在路上奔波。你们是不是更多地在路上奔波？你们其实不需要赚钱。但是你们对现在这种商业平衡方式有何感受，比如外出巡演与卖专辑、呆在家里的比例关系？好吧，显然这发生了很大的变化，
and the ratio of that. Well, obviously it's changed quite a bit. And in your guys' industry, some of the same things that we were dealing with 20 years ago are happening. I mean, big picture, and I know this may sound like a little bit of a cop out. I'm just happy that fucking anybody cares about what we're doing and she'll stop to see us play
这种比例关系也是如此。好吧，显然这发生了很大的变化，在你们的行业里，我们20年前正在处理的一些事情现在也正在发生。从宏观角度来看，我知道这听起来可能有点像借口，我只是很高兴他妈的居然有人关心我们在做什么，并且还会停下来看我们演出，
and still stream or buy or steal our records or whatever. It, the engagement in self, I think, is the triumph and the victory. Obviously, it's way, way harder for a lot of the younger bands nowadays because they don't get the support of the record companies nowadays because they don't get the support of the record companies for basic things, just like gear and tour support. So there is very much of a different thing. It's, I just, you know, talent, good songwriting eventually will find a home with a larger group of people
依然在流媒体上听、买或者盗版我们的唱片之类的。这种互动本身，我认为就是一种凯旋和胜利。显然，对于当今许多年轻乐队来说，情况要困难得多、困难得多，因为他们如今无法获得唱片公司的支持，无论是基本的设备还是巡演支持。所以情况大不相同。我只是觉得，你知道，才华、优秀词曲创作最终会吸引更大的一群人找到一个归宿，
and whether you do it from your bedroom or through a record company or whatever. I believe that everybody will be heard eventually if they're talented, but it is tough. It's tough for a lot of the younger bands out there and for a lot of the bands that, you know, 20 years ago could make a living playing clubs or theaters or have in a harder time now because they don't sell as many records and you really have to be out there and pushing it.
不管你是从卧室里还是通过唱片公司还是其他什么途径。我相信只要有才华，每个人最终都会被听到，但这确实很难。对于许多年轻乐队来说这很难，而且对于许多在20年前可以通过在俱乐部或剧院演出谋生、或者现在日子更不好过的乐队来说也很难，因为他们卖不出那么多唱片，你真的必须身处其中去努力推销。
Do you feel like when you go and you make a record, like your new record, 72 seasons that you guys made, that came out this year and that you're touring, I think you're touring this year on, right? This is what the, on the new record. When you make that new record, when you guys have conversations about it coming out, like are you guys like, or I don't know, the record company or whoever,
当你去制作一张唱片时，比如你们制作的新唱片《72个季节》（72 Seasons），今年刚发行的这张，而且你们正在进行巡演，我想你们今年正在巡演，对吧？就是为了这张新唱片。当你制作那张新唱片时，当你们讨论它发行的时候，你们是不是会觉得，或者我不知道，唱片公司或其他什么人，
it's such a different approach because you're not going to the record store, it's not sending out vinyl or it's not sending out CDs or it's not sending out. It's like load, load up the, the streamer or does that play it all into it? Yeah, I mean, it's the key thing, you know, as an artist, I think when you, you write songs and it's the same with you guys, you want to start a conversation. You want people to engage. You want people to hear your music.
这是一种截然不同的方法，因为你不会去唱片店，它不会寄出黑胶唱片，也不会寄出CD，或者不会寄出。这就像是，把流媒体填满，或者这根本不重要？是的，我的意思是，这是关键所在，作为一个艺术家，我认为当你创作歌曲时，你们也是一样，你想开启一场对话。你想让人产生共鸣。你想让人们听到你的音乐。
How they hear it, I guess, eventually become second tier. And you understand that it's a changed model than it was 25 years ago, 50 years ago, or whatever. I think that in our know, in our band, we just love writing songs and we love making records. We love the creative process and that's, there are a lot of bands that have been around as long as we have that simply don't want to make records anymore because it either
他们如何听到它，我猜，最终退居其次。而且你明白，这是一个与25年前、50年前或其他任何时候都不同的模式。我认为在我们的乐队里，我们只是喜欢写歌，我们喜欢制作唱片。我们喜欢创作过程，就是这样，有很多像我们一样资历的乐队，根本不想再制作唱片了，因为要么
doesn't work for them or the business model of it doesn't work for them and I can't speak for everybody else. We love writing songs. Being creative is a significant part of who we are and it gives us a chance to you know what what makes us stay functioning is that we go from writing to recording to playing gigs to writing to home. We're always changing up what we're doing. So we never get stuck in the sameness over and over. And so we're not always on the road. We're not always in the studio.
这对他们不管用，或者它的商业模式对他们不管用，我不能代表其他人。我们喜欢写歌。富有创造力是我们身份中至关重要的一部分，它给了我们一个机会，你知道，让我们保持运转的原因是我们从创作到录音，再到演出，再到创作，再到回家。我们一直在改变我们在做的事情。所以我们从不会一遍又一遍地陷入同样的泥潭。所以我们不会总是奔波在路上。我们不会总是待在录音室里。
We're not always taking our kids to school or whatever we're not always doing the same thing. So you have to kind of keep just breaking it up and changing what you're doing. And so obviously, I understand that we're exceptionally fortunate, but our success gives us the opportunity to to sort of do all that. And but we would be if if somebody said you can't write or make records anymore, we would probably stop what we're doing because it's such an essential part of just our existence.
我们并不总是送孩子上学什么的，我们不总是在做同一件事。所以你得不断地打破常规，改变你正在做的事情。显然，我明白我们极其幸运，但我们的成功让我们有机会去做到这一切。但是，如果有人对我们说，‘你们不能再写作或制作唱片了’，我们可能会停下手中的活儿，因为这是我们生存中不可或缺的一部分。
Sure, sure. And I love, by the way, I love that you didn't say exceptionally lucky you said it for you because you're not lucky. It wasn't luck that you guys got here. You guys are talented, but you do recognize the full story. You also have nowhere at minute 1590, as it said storyteller.
当然，当然。顺便说一下，我很喜欢你刚才没说‘极其幸运’，而是说‘幸运’，因为你们并不是靠运气。你们走到这一步并不是靠运气。你们很有才华，但你们确实看清了事情的全貌。就像在第1590秒提到的那样，你也是个讲故事的人。
I know it's true, it's true, he's not so story-tellier. We, Lord, I have a list of words here not know it's true. It's true. He's not saying storyteller. We love the Lord. I have a list of words you're not to say on podcast. That's number seven. Yes. If we if we if we got a hold of if we got a hold of your personal music device, whatever it is that you that you use when you're like working out on when you're cycling or whatever doing whatever what's on there.
我知道这是真的，这是真的，他不太会讲故事。我们，天哪，我这里有一张不能说的词汇表，不知道是不是真的。这是真的。他说的不是讲故事的人。我们热爱上帝。我有一张不能在播客里说的词汇表。那是第七个。是的。如果我们如果我们如果我们拿到了如果我们拿到了你的个人音乐播放器，不管你用的是什么，当你锻炼时，当你骑自行车时，或者无论你在做什么，上面都有什么。
What do you listen? What gets you going? What do you like to listen to? Currently, I don't mean of all time, Mrs. Erly. It's very varied, obviously. I'll still circle those deep purple records from 50 years ago that I... Is there a genre you're not a fan of?
你听什么？什么能让你嗨起来？你喜欢听什么？目前，我不是指历年来的所有音乐，埃利太太。显然种类非常繁多。我还是会偶尔听听50年前的那些深紫（Deep Purple）唱片，我……有没有你不太喜欢的音乐风格？
No, I mean, I listen to everything from rock music, to jazz music, to reggae, to pop, to hip hop, R&B. I think the easiest way to answer is, and forgive me again, if it sounds like a cop-op, but there really are only two kinds of music. There's great music and less great music, and so in hard rock, there's great music and less great music, just so in hard rock, there's there's great music and less great music, just like in pop or in reggae, you know, a couple days ago, driving back from rehearsals
不，我的意思是，我听各种音乐，从摇滚乐、爵士乐、雷鬼、流行音乐、到嘻哈、R&B。我想最简单的回答是，再次请原谅，如果这听起来像是在打官腔，但实际上真的只有两种音乐。伟大的音乐和没那么伟大的音乐，所以在硬摇滚里，有伟大的音乐和没那么伟大的音乐，就像在流行音乐或雷鬼乐里一样，你知道的，几天前，从大都会人寿体育场的彩排开车回来
out at MetLife Stadium. We were we're just going to think to a... We love Brunsky. I was pumping some bronsky beat and some... It's a one. Jimmy Somerville. Yeah, Jimmy Somerville. Beat boy, beat boy, hit that perfect beat boy. No way.
在外面。我们当时正准备去听……我们热爱布朗斯基（Brunsky）。我当时在放一些布朗斯基节拍（Bronsky Beat）和一些……就是这个。吉米·萨默维尔（Jimmy Somerville）。是的，吉米·萨默维尔。Beat boy, beat boy, hit that perfect beat boy. 不会吧。
And you're listening to the happy Mondays. We're really listening to Stone Rose and Stone Rose. Tristan Memele, man. You know you speak so, man. Oh, Stone Rose of Fools. Who's gold? I love Stone Rose. Dinner, dinner Rose of Fools, go. I love Stone Rose. Dinner, dinner, dinner, dinner, and listen to that. So it's a lot of varied stuff.
然后你在听快乐星期一（Happy Mondays）。我们其实在听石玫瑰（Stone Roses）和石玫瑰。特里斯坦·梅梅莱，老兄。你知道你说话的样子，老兄。哦，石玫瑰之愚。谁是黄金？我爱石玫瑰。Dinner, dinner Rose of Fools, go. 我爱石玫瑰。Dinner, dinner, dinner, dinner，听听那个。所以有各种各样的东西。
A lot of varied stuff. To a lot of time. Lars, we're in the same, we're in the same. What about listening to a full album? And like since, since, people don't, yeah, people don't really buy albums as much as they used to. They're sort of pulling down kind of a single song here, Alacart there, whereas like Pink Floyd,
各种各样的东西。很多很多次。拉尔斯，我们是一样的，我们是一样的。听一张完整的专辑感觉如何？就像自从，自从，人们不，是的，人们不像以前那样经常买专辑了。他们有点像在这里挑一首单曲，在那里点一首单曲，而像平克·弗洛伊德（Pink Floyd）
the wall comes to mind where there's a whole through line, a thread, a continuity, a thematic that goes throughout the whole album because bands knew that people would potentially buy an entire album. Is that a single? You're saying it to a history? And you're saying that they're telling us to. I'm all around it, but I'm not going to say it. You were so close to it. But like,
《迷墙》（The Wall）就浮现在脑海中，里面有一条贯穿始终的主线、线索、连续性、主题，贯穿整张专辑，因为乐队知道人们可能会购买整张专辑。那是一首单曲吗？你是在对历史说吗？你是在说他们在告诉我们……我大致知道，但我不会说。你离得太近了。但是，
do you think that that will ever kind of happen again? Where there's like a like a rock opera that's kind of like Tommy. Yeah, it's in the beginning to not and not in the classic sense that you're saying it. I mean, there's a great band who we've had played with us the last couple years called Greta Van Fleet. Oh, that love that those guys are great. And they have a they still write longer songs. They, you know, appeal to a very young audience and they still do like crazy long guitar solos. They're really, really great songwriters. They're very dramatic. They're very theatrical, those kids, man.
你认为这种情况还会再次发生吗？那种类似于摇滚歌剧的东西，就像《汤米》（Tommy）。是的，在开始的时候没有，也不是你所说的那种经典意义上的。我的意思是，过去几年里有一个很棒的乐队和我们一起演出，叫做格雷塔·范·弗利特（Greta Van Fleet）。哦，太棒了，那些家伙太棒了。他们仍然写很长的歌。他们，你知道的，吸引非常年轻的观众，他们仍然做疯狂的超长吉他独奏。他们真的是非常非常棒的词曲创作者。那些孩子们，老兄，非常富有戏剧性，非常具有剧场感。
Yes, they're cool. But super cool. We've had them with us playing a special guest for the last couple of years to our last shows. But I don't think that... Yeah, but let me tell you something. Jason's idea is good because here's the thing. In Hamilton, the musical Hamilton, it's rapping.
是的，他们很酷。但是超级酷。在过去几年里，他们作为特别嘉宾和我们一起在我们的最后几场演出中登台。但我不认为……是的，但让我告诉你一件事。杰森的主意很好，因为情况是这样的。在《汉密尔顿》（Hamilton）这部音乐剧里，里面全是说唱。
Everybody wraps. It's like, a musical that, people would be floored if you guys used your music or create a new music with your sound. It's never been done. I'm not going to do a musical. What about a musical, ours? That's what I'm saying.
每个人都在说唱。这就像是一部音乐剧，如果你们用你们的音乐或者用你们的声音创作一新音乐，人们会惊掉下巴的。这从未被做过。我才不做音乐剧呢。音乐剧怎么样，拉尔斯？这就是我要说的。
Come on. Let's make some, let's make some news right now. I love the reaction to this face. No, I can see his face. That's a, yeah, guys, we've got it. There it is. The tale of the music. You can use it. Laura, let me ask you this before we're looking for you.
拜托。让我们搞点，让我们现在就弄出点新闻来。我喜欢这个表情的反应。不，我能看到他的脸。这是一个，是的，伙计们，我们搞定拉。就是这样。音乐的故事。你可以用它。拉尔斯，在我们为你寻找之前，我问你个问题。
An exclusive. Is that what we're doing? No, we're not, we're not getting into musicals. Sean, for once, just one guest, just leave them out of musicals. Yes. Stop getting everyone on the board. He wants to fucking nobody likes musicals. Lars doesn't like cats. I know. He doesn't. I, listen, I saw Hamilton. I saw OG Hamilton. Yeah. OG OG and was as blown away as everybody else and subsequently saw what four times.
一个独家爆料？我们这是在干嘛呢？不，我们不，我们不涉足音乐剧。肖恩，破例一次，就一个嘉宾，别扯上音乐剧。是的。别再把所有人拉下水了。他想他妈的……没人喜欢音乐剧。拉尔斯不喜欢《猫》。我知道。他不喜欢。我，听着，我看过《汉密尔顿》。我看过原版《汉密尔顿》。是的。原版，原版，和其他人一样被震撼到了，后来又看了四次。
And think that Lynn is amazing. I'm going to challenge the credible on this planet. Oh, it's talent. It's talent. I went back later that night and just like Google then YouTube as much as I could. That clip where he's in the White House, like five, six years earlier,
并且觉得林（Lin）太棒了。我要挑战这个星球上最令人难以置信的……哦，这是才华。这就是才华。那天晚上的晚些时候我又回去，在谷歌和油管上尽可能多地搜索。那个他在白宫的片段，大概是五、六年前的，
did you guys see that clip? So Hamilton came out in about 16. This is what oh nine, he was in the White House and was telling Obama and the rest of the gathered there that he was working on a musical about Alexander Hamilton. Yeah, and everybody was just laughing. Yeah.
你们看到那个片段了吗？所以《汉密尔顿》大约在16年问世。这是09年，他在白宫，告诉奥巴马和聚集在那里的其他人，他正在创作一部关于亚历山大·汉密尔顿的音乐剧。是的，每个人都在笑。是的。
And then he did like, he did the first five minutes of it afterwards that he got like standing a face. Yeah, he's a genius. He is. Fucking never seen that clip, Jason. No, I'm going to check it out. Oh, it's, you got to check it out. It's just a piano in him rapping.
然后他做了个，他在事后表演了前五分钟，然后他得到了起立鼓掌。是的，他是天才。他是。他妈的从来没看过那个片段，杰森。不，我要去看看。哦，这，你得去看看。那只是一架钢琴和他的说唱。
Yeah. Oh, that's great. Or something like that. check it out. It's just a piano and him rapping. Oh, that's great. Or something like that. Really fucking crazy. Yeah, he's a mega talent. He's a mega talent and guess what? I'll tell you what, let's meet, I'll meet you halfway. Okay.
是的。哦，太棒了。诸如此类的。去看看吧。那只是一架钢琴和他的说唱。哦，太棒了。诸如此类的。真他妈疯狂。是的，他是超级天才。他是一个超级天才，你猜怎么着？我告诉你，我们见个面，我折中一下。好吧。
Okay. My sense is it's going well. So when Metallica has some musical news, you guys can break it. Yes, I love it. I love that. I love this for you. If you'll have me back even just five minutes and we can break it. Yes. I love that. I love that. I love that. I love that. If you'll have me back even just five minutes and we can make it an exclusive for us. You're the fourth host. You're the fourth. You're the fourth. You're the fourth. You're the fourth. You're the fourth. You're the fourth. You're the fourth. You're the fourth. You're the fourth. You're the fourth. You're the fourth. You're the fourth. You're the fourth. You're the fourth. You're the fourth. You're the fourth. You're the fourth. You're the fourth. You're the fourth. You're the fourth. You're the fourth. You're the fourth. You're the fourth. You're the fourth. You're the fourth. You're the fourth. You're the fourth. You're the fourth. You're the fourth. You're the fourth. You're the fourth. You're the fourth. You're the fourth. You're the fourth. You're the fourth. You're the fourth. You're the fourth. You're the fourth. You're the fourth. You're the fourth. You're the fourth. You're the fourth. You're the fourth. You're the fourth. You're the fourth. You're the fourth. You're the fourth. You're the fourth. You're the fourth. You're the fourth. You're the fourth. You're the fourth. You're the fourth. You're the fourth. You're the fourth. You're the fourth. You're the fourth. You're the fourth. You're the fourth. You're the fourth. You're the fourth. You're the fourth. You're the fourth. You're the fourth. You're the fourth. You're the fourth. You're the fourth. You're the fourth. You're the fourth. You're the fourth. You're the fourth. You're the fourth. You're the fourth take you to the market for us. He did, you're a man.
好吧。我觉得进展顺利。所以当 Metallica 有什么音乐新闻时，你们可以爆料。是的，我喜欢。我喜欢这样。我为你们感到高兴。如果你能让我回来哪怕五分钟，我们就能独家爆料。是的。我喜欢这样。我喜欢这样。我喜欢这样。我喜欢这样。如果你能让我回来哪怕五分钟，我们就能把它做成我们的独家新闻。你是第四个主持人。你是第四个。你是第四个。你是第四个。你是第四个。你是第四个。你是第四个。你是第四个。你是第四个。你是第四个。你是第四个。你是第四个。你是第四个。你是第四个。你是第四个。你是第四个。你是第四个。你是第四个。你是第四个。你是第四个。你是第四个。你是第四个。你是第四个。你是第四个。你是第四个。你是第四个。你是第四个。你是第四个。你是第四个。你是第四个。你是第四个。你是第四个。你是第四个。你是第四个。你是第四个。你是第四个。你是第四个。你是第四个。你是第四个。你是第四个。你是第四个。你是第四个。你是第四个。你是第四个。你是第四个。你是第四个。你是第四个。你是第四个。你是第四个。你是第四个。你是第四个。你是第四个。你是第四个。你是第四个。你是第四个。你是第四个。你是第四个。你是第四个。你是第四个。你是第四个。你是第四个。你是第四个。你是第四个。你是第四个。你是第四个。你是第四个。你是第四个。你是第四个。你是第四个。你是第四个。你是第四个。你是第四个。你是第四个。你是第四个。你是第四个。你是第四个。你是第四个。你是第四个。你是第四个。你是第四个。你是第四个。你是第四个。你是第四个。你是第四个。你是第四个。你是第四个。你是第四个。你是第四个。你是第四个。你是第四个。你是第四个。你是第四个。你是第四个。你是第四个。你是第四个。你是第四个。你是第四个。你是第四个。你是第四个。你是第四个。你是第四个。你是第四个。你是第四个。你是第四个。你是第四个。你是第四个。你是第四个。你是第四个。你是第四个。你是第四个。你是第四个。你是第四个。你是第四个。你是第四个。你是第四个。你是第四个。你是第四个。你是第四个。你是第四个。你是第四个。你是第四个。你是第四个。你是第四个。你是第四个。你是第四个。你是第四个。你是第四个。你是第四个。你是第四个。你是第四个。你是第四个。你是第四个。你是第四个。你是第四个。你是第四个。你是第四个。你是第四个。你是第四个。你是第四个。你是第四个。你是第四个。你是第四个。你是第四个。你是第四个。你是第四个。你是第四个。你是第四个。你是第四个。你是第四个。你是第四个。你是第四个。你是第四个。你是第四个。你是第四个。你是第四个。你是第四个。你是第四个。你是第四个。你是第四个。你是第四个。你是第四个。你是第四个。你是第四个。你是第四个。你是第四个。你是第四个。你是第四个。你是第四个。你是第四个。你是第四个。你是第四个。你是第四个。你是第四个。你是第四个。你是第四个。你是第四个。你是第四个。你是第四个。你是第四个。你是第四个。你是第四个。你是第四个。你是第四个。你是第四个。你是第四个。你是第四个。你是第四个。你是第四个。你是第四个。你是第四个。你是第四个。你是第四个。你是第四个。你是第四个。你是第四个。你是第四个。你是第四个。你是第四个。你是第四个。你是第四个。你是第四个。你是第四个。你是第四个。你是第四个。你是第四个。你是第四个。你是第四个。你是第四个。你是第四个。你是第四个。你是第四个。你是第四个。你是第四个。你是第四个。你是第四个。你是第四个。你是第四个。你是第四个。你是第四个。你是第四个。你是第四个。你是第四个。你是第四个。你是第四个。你是第四个。你是第四个。你是第四个。你是第四个。你是第四个。你是第四个。你是第四个。你是第四个。你是第四个。你是第四个。你是第四个。你是第四个。你是第四个。你是第四个。你是第四个。你是第四个。你是第四个。你是第四个。你是第四个。你是第四个。你是第四个。你是第四个。你是第四个。你是第四个。你是第四个。你是第四个。你是第四个。你是第四个。你是第四个。你是第四个。你是第四个。你是第四个。你是第四个。你是第四个。你是第四个。你是第四个。你是第四个。你是第四个。你是第四个。你是第四个。你是第四个。你是第四个。你是第四个。你是第四个。你是第四个。你是第四个。你替我们向市场兜售了它。真的，你是个汉子。
Wow. We was going great to you. We can get into, I read about William Freak and also this morning, or yesterday, and I understand the no mentioning of the great films that he made, and et cetera, et cetera, et cetera. And I did read about the, so people know it because of this strike we can't mention them.
哇。我们刚才聊得真棒。我们可以进入，我今天早上也读到了关于威廉·弗里德金（William Friedkin）的内容，或者昨天，我理解不能提及他拍过的伟大电影等等等等。我确实读到了关于……所以大家知道是因为这次罢工我们不能提及它们。
Just a tracinac. Yeah, no, I'm right there with Lars Yeah, listen, he was he was another genius too and I and I and I again I don't want to embarrass you, but you're a genius man. You you've made so much great music for so long Yeah, such a fan you're a nice guy. Yeah, that's that's the that's the patient You don't have to be in you all right vibe and you're such a great dude and it was such a pleasure meeting you all those years ago and having you on your Right back at talking you man And just like I've known you
简直是个悲剧。是的，不，我和拉尔斯感同身受。是的，听着，他也是另一个天才，我，我，我再次声明，我不想让你尴尬，但你是个天才，老兄。你为我们创作了那么多伟大的音乐，时间跨度这么长。是的，我是你的超级粉丝，你是个好人。是的，这，这才是，这才是关键。你不需要摆架子，一切都很好，你的磁场太棒了，多年前见到你并让你……真是太荣幸了。说得对，老兄。就像我认识你一样。
Continued success dude. Well, thank you. Thanks. I have to get back out. Get back here. We'll go hang out with coupe Let's do it. He's gonna cover him. So I'm sitting up in my publicist's office here in in down in Tribeca And I walked in and was handed this piece of paper. I go, wow, this is high tech. Yeah, I care. Yeah. No limits here. We are top of the heap over here.
继续成功，老兄。好的，谢谢。谢谢。我得回去了。回到这儿。我们要去和库普一起闲逛。就这么办。他会接替他。所以我坐在特里贝卡（Tribeca）的公关办公室里。我走进去，手里被塞了这张纸。我说，哇，这太高科技了。是的，我在乎。是的。这里没有限制。我们这里是顶尖人物。
It's marvelous. Thank you for saying yes to this guy. Thanks for having me. Thanks for being your pick, Will. I enjoyed the time a couple years ago in France. And it's great to see you guys. It's nice to meet you. Nice to meet you too.
这太棒了。谢谢你答应这家伙。谢谢邀请我。谢谢你选了我，威尔。我很享受几年前在法国的那段时光。很高兴见到你们。很高兴认识你。我也很高兴认识你。
And good luck on the rest of the tour. Yeah. When we have musical news, we'll break it with you. I love it. It would be honor. Thank you, Lars. Thanks, buddy. See you soon.
祝你们接下来的巡演一切顺利。好的。当我们有音乐新闻时，我们会第一时间向你们爆料。我喜欢。这将是我的荣幸。谢谢你，拉尔斯。谢谢，老兄。回头见。
Thank you, man. Bye. Bye, bye, bye. Wow. That was a great gett Willie. Yeah. You know, it's the interesting about him is, you know, I wasn't one to run out and buy Metallica.
谢谢你，老兄。再见。拜拜，拜拜，拜拜。哇。威利，那真是一次棒极了的采访。是的。你知道，关于他的有趣之处在于，你知道，我不是那种会抢着去买 Metallica 专辑的人。
Obviously, I like their songs and know a lot of them and was a fan of them growing up too. But it's rare that the drummer is as famous as the band. It's true. Well, who else? Phil Collins. Phil Collins. Yeah, but Lars and James started
显然，我喜欢他们的歌，也知道很多，从小也是他们的粉丝。但鼓手和乐队一样出名的情况很少见。确实。好吧，还有谁？菲尔·柯林斯（Phil Collins）。菲尔·柯林斯。是的，但是拉尔斯和詹姆斯一起创立了
the band right so they formed it together. So you had guitarist and drummer like WAM band. Yeah, I guess I guess boy, that might be the first connection there. Yeah. So which one would Andrew Ritchley be? I guess it would be Lars. Huh, okay. Let's get Lars back on the lower way. And by the way, and let's get James on here real quick, you know what I mean? James that makes you George. So I guess. No, you really very very cool.
乐队，对吧，所以他们是一起组建的。所以你有了吉他手和鼓手，就像威猛乐队（Wham!）一样。是的，我想，我想，天哪，这可能是最早的联系吧。是的。那么安德鲁·里奇利（Andrew Ridgeley）会是谁？我想那会是拉尔斯。哈，好吧。让我们把拉尔斯再请回劳威（lower way）。顺便说一句，我们快把詹姆斯也请到这里来，你知道我的意思吗？詹姆斯，那就让你当乔治。所以我想。不，你真的很酷。
He's so cool. He's such a cool dude and he does have such a great vibe and he's so, I don't know, he's, I just love the way you can really access all everything when you ask him a question and he can really access it and he's so sort of concise and he's so quick and. Yes, I like that he's open to sharing anything. Yeah, yeah, I love that. I thought it's a key to keeping a little, a little grip together.
他太酷了。他是个超级酷的家伙，他确实有着极好的磁场，而且他是那样的，我不知道，他，我就是喜欢你问他问题时他能真正触及所有事情的方式，他能真正深入核心，而且他是如此的简练，如此的敏捷。是的，我喜欢他乐于分享任何事情。是的，是的，我喜欢这样。我认为这是保持一个小团队凝聚力的关键。
It's just don't be a dick. Yeah, okay. Yeah, 100%. You see me looking at you, Sean and Will. No, he's looking at me. He's looking at me. No, you're looking in the mirror, you're looking in the mirror. No, not looking at my square. You're square. Just laptop. You're gonna see I can't believe we miss them at giant or met life, whatever. I think it's a great idea if they open for us.
那就是别当混蛋。是的，好吧。是的，百分之百。你看到我在看着你了吧，肖恩和威尔。不，他在看着我。他在看着我。不，你在照镜子，你在照镜子。不，没看我的方框。你是方框。只有笔记本电脑。你会看到……真不敢相信我们在巨人体育场或大都会人寿（Metlife）错过了他们，随便吧。我觉得如果他们为我们暖场是个极好的主意。
But we should leave you as close. If you ask for metallic. It's so great that he was offering. I'm pretty sure he was offering to open for us. Yeah, let's wait till they get a little closer to Los Angeles. I know, but they are because they're on tour for their record 72 seasons. And it would be great to go and we should definitely go see them in Los Angeles. That'd be so fun. That'd be fine.
但我们应该让你作为压轴。如果你去问 Metallica。他主动提出暖场真是太棒了。我很确信他当时是在主动提出为我们暖场。是的，让我们等他们离洛杉矶近一点再说。我知道，但他们确实在巡演，为了他们的专辑《72个季节》（72 Seasons）。去看看会很棒，我们绝对应该去洛杉矶看他们的演出。那会非常有趣。那会很好的。
I would love to see. I'm going to go see Tate Tate tomorrow night. Are you? I think that's what is not what kids or kids are calling her. Tate Tate's lefty. Yeah. Are you going to Tate Tate tomorrow? Yeah.
我很想看。我明天晚上要去去看泰特·泰特（Tate Tate）。是吗？我想那就是……孩子们是怎么称呼她的？泰特·泰特的左撇子。是的。你明天要去去看泰特·泰特吗？是的。
Yeah. Yeah. Are you taking Franny and MAP? No, no, just solo. Just a one. Just a one. It's going to be in the parking lot with a little sign. Single.
是的。是的。你带弗兰妮（Franny）和马普（Map）去吗？不，不，就我一个人。单人行。就一个。要在停车场举着一个小牌子。单身。
Single. Single. Anyone got a single? No, it will be a full family. Thanks video of your self to alone. Yeah, she's part of the family and we're all going to go and a self driver over. No, I'll be self driving, you know, don't drink anymore. So I know, I know, but I know how you know, we get into the state, where's it? So if I it's at so far, yeah, And apparently you got to pick an album to sort of dress as, and I don't know.
单身。单身。有人有单身吗？不，那会是一整个家庭。感谢你一个人去。是的，她是家庭的一员，我们都会去，然后自己开车过去。不，我会自己开车，你知道的，我不再喝酒了。所以我知道，我知道，但我知道你懂的，我们进入那种状态时，在哪儿呢？所以如果我……是在萨福（SoFi），是的。而且显然你得挑一张专辑来假扮封面，我不知道。
Name one of our albums, one. Name one of our albums. I couldn't. I'm going to go ahead and see what I'm wearing right now. That's what it'll be tomorrow night. Oh, you know what I refer to that is the, the, the, the, fuck it. Yeah. Yeah.
说出我们的一张专辑，一张。说出我们的一张专辑。我说不出来。我这就来看看我现在穿的是什么。明天晚上就会是那个造型。哦，你知道我管那个叫什么吗，就是，那个，那个，管他妈的。是的。是的。
Yeah. You got a lot of buckets. Wasn't George Costanza's, if you wear sweats, you're were a sweats, you're telling the world you've given up? I mean, I guess so. There it is, Sean is giving up. Oh, look, Sean. Look, I have something to say. If Metallica can't open for us at every single leg of our tour,
是的。你有很多管他妈的。乔治·科斯坦扎（George Costanza）不是说过吗，如果你穿运动裤，你就是在向全世界宣告你已经放弃了？我的意思是，大概是吧。就是这样，肖恩已经放弃了。哦，看，肖恩。听着，我有话要说。如果 Metallica 不能在我们巡演的每一个分站为我们暖场，
if we tour again, they should just do at least at one of them or two of them just do a fly. Bye! Don't do the flying. Don't do the flying. Bye, smart. Bye, smart. Bye, smart.
如果我们再次巡演，他们至少应该在其中一站或两站做个快闪。再见！别做什么快闪。别做什么快闪。拜，聪明。拜，聪明。拜，聪明。
Smart. Bye. Smartless is 100% organic and artisanally handcrafted by Michael Grant Terry, Rob Armjav, and Bennett Barberco. Our next episode will be out in a week wherever you listen to podcasts, or you can listen to it right now early on Amazon Music, or early and ad-free by subscribing to Wondry Plus in Apple Podcasts or the Wondry app. Every big moment starts with a big dream. But what happens when that big dream turns out to be a big flop. From Wondry and Atwell Media, I'm Misha Brown and this is the big flop. Every week, comedians join me to chronicle the biggest flugs, fails, and blunders of all time like Quibi.
聪明。再见。SmartLess 由迈克尔·格兰特·特里（Michael Grant Terry）、罗布·阿尔姆杰夫（Rob Armojiev）和贝内特·巴尔伯科（Bennett Barbakow）100%有机手工打造。我们的下一期节目将在下周发布，无论你在哪里听播客都可以收听，或者你现在就可以在亚马逊音乐（Amazon Music）上提前收听，或者通过在苹果播客（Apple Podcasts）或 Wondry App 上订阅 Wondry Plus 来享受无广告的提前收听。每一个伟大的时刻都始于一个伟大的梦想。但是当那个伟大的梦想变成一场惨败时会发生什么呢。来自 Wondry 和 Atwell Media，我是米莎·布朗（Misha Brown），这里是《大惨败》（The Big Flop）。每周都有喜剧演员和我一起记录史上最大的惨败、失败和失误，比如 Quibi。
It's kind of like when you give yourself your own nickname and you try to like get other people to do it. And the 2019 movie adaptation of... Cats. Like if I'm watching the dancing and I'm noticing the feet aren't touching the ground, there's something wrong with the movie. Find out what happens when massive hype turns into major fiasco. Enjoy the Big Flop on the Wondery app or wherever you get your podcasts. You can listen to the Big Flop early and ad-free on Wondery Plus.
这有点像当你给自己起个外号，然后试图让别人也这么叫你一样。以及2019年的电影改编版……《猫》（Cats）。就像如果我在看舞蹈，而我注意到脚根本没有着地，那这部电影就有问题了。找出当巨大的炒作变成重大惨败时会发生什么。在 Wondry App 或你获取播客的任何地方欣赏《大惨败》。你可以在 Wondry Plus 上提前且无广告地收听《大惨败》。
Get started with your free trial at Wondery.com slash plus. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
立即在 wondry.com/plus 开始你的免费试用。本期节目暂无评论。点击字幕中的任意句子即可发表评论。